Hello freaks.
What the fuck's going on?
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by legal zoom.
What is legal zoom?
Legal Zoom is a way to handle a lot of shit that you would ordinarily have to go
to an actual attorney and make an appointment and go into an office and pay an
exorbitant fee per hour.
Instead,
you can handle a lot of that shit yourself from your house while naked and drunk
and it's legal.
Yes,
legal zoom is not a law firm,
but what they do is they provide you with self help services and if the shit
hits the fan and you're panicking,
they can also connect you with an independent third party attorney.
So what you can do on legal zooms a lot of stuff that you would have to go to a
lawyer's office for,
like you can create a last will just 69 bucks.
You can start a business incorporate and form an LLC for starting at just 99
bucks.
Super easy to do all this stuff.
In fact,
Brian Bread band has done it himself.
You've actually done it.
You made actual legal work over there.
At four in the morning I created desk squad.
They goes down,
which he goes,
you can make an LSC until it'd be irresponsible and do all this horrible thing
that Doug don't expose the flaws and the governments.
You're not supposed to do that.
While we're doing a commercial legal zoom has no connection whatsoever to any of
the opinions of Brian Redman is has expressed.
Those are his and his alone.
They also do not represent the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Anyway.
In the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal zoom and they've saved a ton of money.
Can you tell that I didn't write that.
That part.
See,
I was my acting,
but I'm not good at and you get a special discount from listening to this
podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the referral box at checkout.
For more savings,
go to legal zoom.com and see how they can help you out today.
Freak bitches were also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com it's o.
N.
I.
T.
If you have never been and you've never listened to this podcast,
then this will be new.
If you've listened to this podcast,
you,
you're going to be like,
can this motherfucker say the same thing again?
Unfortunately,
yes.
There's no other way to do this.
Um,
what on it is for those who don't know is a human optimization website.
That's what we call ourselves.
Sounds pretentious,
but the intentions are pure.
What we're trying to do is sell you the best shit we can find,
whether it's strength and conditioning equipment like kettlebells,
whether it's foods like they're the new warrior bar,
which is just like really delicious and actually nutritious buffalo bar and made
the ancient native American way.
We just started getting these,
they're made with cranberries and pepper,
no antibiotics,
no added hormones.
It's gluten free.
No nitrates is actually good for you.
14 grams of protein and a very low in fat as well.
Um,
four grams of fat per two ounce serving and it's healthy fat.
This is,
this is all like organic buffalo meat.
Interesting stuff is,
you know,
we always think like,
oh,
I need a snack.
And you just sort of sacrifice that.
You're just going to eat something that's just totally shitty for your body just
to fill that hole and give you calories.
There's ways around that shit.
A hemp force protein bars.
Another one that we have hemp force protein is the stuff that we get from Canada
because we still ever tarted laws here in America.
And you can buy hemp and you can have him,
but you can't grow him and you can't sell it either,
which is a fucking crazy,
but you can sell it once you've already bought it.
You mother fuckers.
What are you doing?
Like a pre workout bar?
It's just a bar.
It's just got protein in it.
It's just hemp.
Uh,
the same hemp force protein that we have in the powder.
It's in the bar.
They're really delicious too there.
They're easy to digest.
That's one of the best things about hemp proteins.
One of the easiest digest.
I really like whey protein.
Um,
I liked the taste of like muscle milk and a lot of those things,
but God damn would they erupt inside my booty hole?
I'd just get the worst farts ever from those things.
I don't know what it is,
man.
It's just me and I'm and way ways that essentially it's a milk protein.
It's just a little bit more difficult for your body to digest,
but barely grassfed whey is easier.
No Asprey sells from grass fed whey I think grass fed ways easier for your body
to digest.
Sort of similar to how grass fed butter is.
Um,
anyway,
on it.com o.
N n I t we sell lots of good shit.
And if you use the code word Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
boom.
That's it.
Oh Hongyan I would just say it.
A lot of our meetings are rejoicing.
I just say Ohanian cause he wanted to be Americanized.
Alexis Ohanian is here,
ladies and gentlemen,
Cuban music.
Brian Redman
experience.
I don't know why we have to have your music.
Could we do I like,
otherwise it does it.
We've done it without the music several times.
We just get fucking crazy.
And we just got,
we said,
you know,
let's do the least produced version of this possible with no professionalism
attached to which is anyway,
which would be hard.
You guys,
you guys had run a tight ship here.
You got to go with your right name,
Dude.
You've got to go with [inaudible].
Yeah,
you got to go with that.
I call these these silly people that can't say that.
Learn how to say that.
Oh,
onion.
Awesome.
The,
well,
I mean,
my father,
so my father was born in the states.
Both of his parents,
uh,
had,
were,
were part of the generation that came over.
So my dad pronounces it handing as well.
So,
but I'll tell you,
I'll tell you what I own.
See that first name?
Alexis.
You never call me Alex.
Oh,
okay.
I like that rope as a little pudgy kid named Alexis.
And you learn real quick to own that name because I was,
I was born in 83 and my father named me after a boxer.
Uh,
Alexis are guayle this Nicaraguan flag.
I know exactly who he is.
I got to see him fight live serious.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I got to see him fight live a long time ago.
Me and my friend Jimmy lawless,
we went down to,
I think it was in Lowell,
Massachusetts.
We saw Alexis are guayle live and we saw Micky ward live before he became famous
and brought my father,
what am I doing here?
Awesome.
It was awesome in Lowell.
It was fucking great.
Low Massachusetts,
which is where Micky Ward was from.
So when you went out there,
but he won't.
Yeah,
I got to see him when he was an up and coming contender alive.
But he's seeing our grail.
That's my pop.
He showed me how he is.
He has a,
an entire closet full of VHS tapes of his fights,
which I keep telling him he needs to do something digitized now.
Like just go on Youtube.
And I got a quick,
quick query.
And um,
he had,
he had a wonderful mustache and amazing left jab and that combination.
Well Alexis Aguayo,
it'll awesome.
His straight right hand was a work of art and a gentleman.
Yeah,
a really,
really good guy.
Like a real man,
a real man's man.
So that's,
that was my name's sake.
He died young,
right?
Didn't,
he did,
it was a suicide.
If you,
I've talked to Nicaraguans about this and there,
you know,
he got very involved politically after his fighting days and there are a lot of
people who believe there was more to that story and that never happens.
Nobody ever kills anybody.
They didn't try to make it look like a suicide.
It's never happened Bro.
It's been snow.
Have you ever snow peas?
I love my Snopes.
Snopes Snopes into a lot of stupid fucking arguments.
Snoop,
real quick.
This is one of the advantages of the interwebs.
I know what you mean.
They're snooping for the facts.
No,
no.
I think it's,
Yeah,
it was snoop sued.
We have to,
oh,
so you can probably check snow on English speaking mother.
Plus if the English language wasn't so goofy and there wasn't any weird
exceptions like that,
it would be so easy to shit on me right now.
But there's a lot of ones that don't make any sense.
It's a pretty fucked up language.
Yeah,
it's is very bizarre.
More bizarre when you're working with,
you know,
where it's like a honeymoon.
I know,
man.
You know,
it's like it fits it or you know,
that's one of the reasons why he got to give sports nigger props.
That's a bowl and goddamn move the guy own Schwartz shots and that guy are knoll
and Arnold to Arnold is fucking,
that's the kid from different strokes.
You know what I mean?
It's not the manliest most manly bodybuilder ever.
He made it though.
Fuck Aa.
Did see,
see Arnold?
Uh,
definitely.
definitely a fighter.
I,
I know I'm not,
I didn't fulfill my father's prophecy and me being a boxer instead,
I guess I'm a,
I'm a lover,
not a fighter.
Well myself,
you figured your own path outs or thank goodness,
thank God for computers.
You don't have to be a fighter like in the physical form.
Obviously you figured out a way to succeed.
He figured out some cool shit for sure.
I mean,
that's what everybody admired about Alexis Arguayo was the same thing that
anybody Meyers about.
Anybody who is involved in the creation of something cool.
And you're involved in the creation of the coolest fucking website on the
Internet.
I,
you're like Dalton read it.
You can't get a better hub of information.
Like when new things,
innovation,
a lot of gossipy bullshit though.
But that's people,
people,
that's what we do as people.
We like to talk shit.
But other than that,
I mean the,
the,
the resource,
if anything is going down anywhere in the world at anytime,
you can pretty much find it,
read it and it gets verified.
The vote up system,
good posts rise to the top,
bad post,
fall down.
It's such a
smart,
cool thing.
And really the model I think for like online discourse when it comes to like
message board type discourse.
I think you guys are the model.
You know,
we,
I mean it's,
it's amazing.
Uh,
when Steve,
Steve Huffman,
my cofounder and I started this thing,
we were in a little apartment in Medford,
Massachusetts.
I lived in Medford,
Medford.
We're on 72.
I feel bad for whoever lives there now.
Can I say that?
No,
don't say it.
Definitely not.
But it's,
no,
I don't want to get in trouble.
Okay.
What's on fucking,
you know,
whatever,
what's with the questions?
But the MEFA Medford.
Yeah.
And it was,
it was a great,
we had just graduated from college,
just graduated Uva,
went up to Boston.
We raised 12 grand from y Combinator,
which would go on to invest in like Dropbox,
Airbnb,
and,
and read it.
And we 12 grand in the bank.
We worked our asses off for three months in that little apartment and built
reddit and to be a top of the website now,
hundred 50 million people a month.
It's crazy.
Love hearing shit like that.
And that's cool.
That's the American dream,
man.
We weren't 100% nerds with,
with,
with 12 grand in the bank total.
We just,
we just worked with a couple of laptops,
no connections and,
and,
and you know,
what's the American dream,
right?
I mean,
the American dream where your parents somewhere in their past,
they're either their parents or their parents' parents were,
came from over from Armenia.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
My fun rest fled the genocide.
And so what year was this?
We're talking about the early 19 hundreds.
Yeah.
So 1915 was going to get started if you want to get really real.
So my birthday is April 24th,
which is the Remembrance Day of the genocide.
So like I'm,
so I'm half Armenian on my father's side.
I'm full on Armenian on my mother's side.
I'm full on German.
She actually immigrated,
she was a fresh off the boat from Deutschland.
Wow.
So it's a really interesting 20th century to your DNA is gone through some shit.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's about those two and a,
and I feel like having,
I mean right there.
Yeah,
certainly from the Armenian side,
you know,
they came out of survival.
My mom actually came for love to marry my dad.
Very romantic.
Um,
but,
but both of them,
right.
The reality was,
um,
leaving her life,
she was on track to be like a pharmacist in Germany,
but coming to the states,
she was just an ignorant like degree lists,
uh,
immigrant,
right.
And quote unquote.
Um,
and so she worked jobs that she had to work just because it was paying the
bills.
Like she worked as an AU pair,
she worked.
And I'm so incredibly proud of what she did to leave a life behind a comfortable
great life in Germany to start fresh here.
Um,
and then obviously my father's family,
like,
you know,
when you grow up with a bunch of Armenians,
real quick how lucky you are to have that sort of genetic lottery of being born
here instead of over there.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I was totally ignorant to,
uh,
the,
the genocide,
um,
until,
uh,
I was interviewing a fighter,
Manny Gambhir Berian after one of his fights and um,
he was dedicating his victory to the victims of the Armenian genocide and he was
like trying to bring awareness to it.
And I was like,
wow.
For him.
Oh,
he's very proud Armenian.
So I had to look it up and find out what it was all about.
But
that's one of those ones that you,
you don't hear about too much another horrific event in human history.
It is a,
it is certainly re really unspoken.
And I,
I'm trying to think,
I discovered system of a down because I was listening to [inaudible] 98 rock
back in Maryland and I heard Sarah talking about the genocide and I was like,
who is on a rock station talking about the Armenian genocide?
And I'm like,
Oh,
Armenia Rock Ben.
Isn't it crazy how one event like that can make,
I mean it's not that Armenians wouldn't be,
have like nationalistic pride or pride of origin before that,
but that one event has everybody bonded together.
There's so much more.
And especially because a lot of folks don't even know about the Armenian
genocide.
It is.
And I was a history major to in school,
so I've thought a lot about this.
Um,
and it's partially because it is unrecognized in Turkey and even here in the u s
on a national level,
but it's this,
I think it's the fact that it's still this open wound and it seems it may seem
mood like I understand the people who committed this are long dead,
but it's,
I think it has such an effect on the psyche cause we're all like,
well hold on,
I missed there to deny the existence that this thing happened is shown
incredibly offensive because it's not doing justice to all the people we know.
It's crazy that we're having this conversation because just 17 hours ago the u s
Senate committee passed and Armenian genocide resolution series.
Yup.
So it's still got to go self go to the house or did it already it says,
I don't know how I'll word it says 12 senators voted for the resolution.
I feel like when I,
when I have to pay attention to how the government works as far like senators
and Congressmen and representatives,
I get angry.
It hurts.
I just shut it off.
I don't know.
Want to know who has to go to who,
you know,
why?
Cause your system sucks.
Broken says such a donkey ass old king system may even people were riding
fucking horses and hurl and bows and arrows at each other's fucking systems
retarded.
You make me know who is it?
Well it has to go through the house and the house pastors are centered around a
concern,
almost passed muster the fuck outta here and dumb.
And it is,
uh,
it has been so co opted by,
by money and,
and,
and it's,
it's frustrating.
It is.
And I am an optimist.
Don't get me wrong,
I still,
I think the Internet,
I mean,
the reason,
the reason in part I wrote the book,
the reason I campaigned against Sopa Pipa was I really believe the Internet can
be a way for us to get the government that we deserve.
I completely agree.
It's just,
it's a process and there's a lot of,
a lot of shit to get through.
What the process really is,
is in change,
changing the way people's minds operate.
And I think that that process without a doubt has already been done.
I think kids of today,
I'm 46 years old,
so anyone who's in their twenties I guess I'd be talking about kids of today,
they're men,
but they're kids.
They are so much more advanced than I ever was when I was at that age than I
was.
I was out fucking monkey.
I knew nothing.
I knew neighborhood couple books,
uh,
you know,
CNN news every now and then.
I knew nothing.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's,
it's amazing
entities.
I visited 77 universities on the tour and it makes me,
it makes me jealous,
frankly.
It makes me very hopeful to kids.
But look,
this is like these kids grew up,
like I remember getting that modem out of 33,
six in middle school.
I remember getting my first PC,
he was a four 86 SX and my parents,
I was lucky enough to get that one.
I got it in middle school.
My parents didn't have a ton of money and they didn't know shit about
technology,
but they knew enough and I got that chance.
And that has provided everything for me.
But their kids coming up today who by and large have known this technology from
jump and they've known,
they have,
they don't even know what a dial up sounds like.
That's insane.
And so they think of knowledge as being something in real time.
Like,
like you were saying earlier,
you know,
we,
we're,
we're sort of developing this attitude of like,
oh,
right,
we can go seek out this information.
We can squelch gossip on Snopes or we can go learn how to do,
we can learn string theory on Khan Academy,
but this generation coming up,
they just,
they take it for granted because they just know,
oh,
I have a problem or I need to figure something out or I want to create something
and share it like the Internet.
Uh,
and that's how,
that's how all of us got to learn the programming languages that helped us build
things like reddit.
But it's helping filmmakers.
Right now it's helping artists.
It's helping photog it's being comedians,
right?
Like think of the wealth of knowledge that the up and coming comic now has to
learn from to look to share.
Like the amount of the resource of just finding things to talk about as long as
they don't.
Men see it though.
I can't do that.
It's horrible.
That's a verb now.
Um,
the,
the like the amount of internet like Internet websites,
Internet search engines,
amount of,
uh,
social media networks,
whether it's Facebook or Twitter,
they just a sheer amount of funny stories that are coming your way as a comic
today.
Yeah.
It's like if you can't write new material,
it's like you're just not paying attention.
It's not like the old days you had to wait for shit to happen.
You never live in fucking Pennsylvania and just looking left and low.
C'Mon.
I can need something to talk about.
Like now you go online,
it's like,
it's constant.
It's overflowing.
Sucks though,
because they not the same comics are also looking at the same news.
Stories are writing jokes about that.
That's totally going to happen.
It's totally going to happen without a doubt.
Like a,
I was doing something about almond milk and somebody,
uh,
let me know on the podcast that what's his face.
Um,
Lewis Black has a great hunk on soy milk.
It's basically the same joke.
And uh,
like you find that out because the Internet too.
But the good thing is like,
I wouldn't have known that unless I then I like that Joe could have made it into
my arsenal and then I wouldn't have even known that Louis Black had it.
And then,
you know,
it'd be,
I would be accused of plagiarism and I would feel stupid.
And you change almond milk to something else.
Like I don't even want important.
It's,
it's a tiny part of the bit,
but because of the Internet,
I know all this and,
and think about it this way,
right?
Like the,
the speed with which you can learn shit.
This is,
this brings everyone up.
Like it forces us.
This is,
and we see this in tech all the time.
Um,
just because of the nature of writing code and creating applications,
you know,
competition is,
this is as efficient as it gets.
There's new stuff coming out every day and it forces you to stay up and to be
innovating
and to be pushing.
And now I think of it as there are so many more in this instance,
like comics who are connected,
who are watching,
who,
who are seeing what someone is doing.
They're like,
all right,
like I'm not going to take that joke,
but now I just gotta I have to,
I have to push harder,
faster.
And on the whole I think we all benefit because we'll get better
jokes.
We human beings benefit.
There's the artistic expression would benefit the real problem with plagiarism,
whether it's in that or blogs,
you see them blogs a lot and I mean people still are getting busted for it.
Yeah,
I remember there was police,
so yeah,
absolutely.
But the difference between the mindset is what's really important.
Like the,
the,
the guy who is an actual writer,
the guy who,
or the girl who's an actual writer,
the girl who's an actual comic,
what they're trying to do is figure shit out and they're trying to find
ridiculous points and things and then make funny observations about those
points.
If you're just copying stuff,
then you're not exercising,
whatever it is the tunes you in to those ideas.
In the first place so the you're lost when you're done.
If you get busted stealing jokes and then you have to write your own,
you're like holy shit,
like I don't even know how to do this.
Like you're like an open miker.
That's why you see like the guys who have been accused of plagiarism,
there's just like a high period in their careers and then this massive drop off
where you look at and you go,
oh my God,
like what the fuck is writing this?
Like this isn't funny at all.
Like you went from being this guy with these really funny points to this monkey
with dog shit coming out of your mouth and what?
What does that for me,
the act good act probably better than your jokes,
but it's because they never really did it in the first place.
They were just stealing and that that mindset there,
they seem to be mutually exclusive.
Like people who are really creative are almost never the type of person that
would even think about plagiarizing.
So it's kind of fascinating how it's a,
but something like reddit exposes that quick like this.
I found out about this,
I found out about this on Twitter,
but they're just social media and just the ability to communicate with people.
It's just,
it's unprecedented.
And,
and you have to,
I mean,
in,
in o five,
two of us in a little apartment,
there was no Twitter,
there was no tumbler.
Facebook is still in colleges.
It's still in like elite colleges.
Back then it was a different world.
But,
and to give credit where it's due,
I mean,
I,
I really,
I do believe we're all standing on the shoulders of giants.
I'm also not my quote,
but like,
you know the message board,
right?
That's nothing new right there.
We had message boards.
I ran a message boarding college,
a forum,
um,
you know,
before that they come out like what was the first year of the message board?
Ah,
well,
I mean really early Internet,
you've got bbs systems.
Um,
you've got,
I mean,
they're like the forum use net forum,
like basic forum software where if someone creates an account,
usually with like a pseudonym,
right?
They create an account,
they post the link or they have a discussion.
This stuff.
This stuff is as old as the Internet,
as the World Wide Web.
What Steve and I got right was we adapted it and modernize it a bit because we
let people,
you know,
at large up vote or down vote,
um,
and,
and essentially,
I mean I hate to simplify it that much,
but reddit is like a next generation forum platform and then what we that dig
and all the dig clones didn't realize was that they were just one front page.
We knew if we were going to win,
we'd have to be a platform for communities.
Dig was a platform for a community,
right?
The front page and only have so much stuff on it.
But we knew,
you know,
Steven,
I knew that we had uh,
you know,
there were things we were interested in,
right?
We're interested in technology,
we're interested in the Redskins were interested in like just football.
Like we might have a certain audience,
but what's going to make this work is if anyone who has a particular community
or a following,
whether you love my little pony and want to create a a read it about that a
subreddit,
which there are lots or do you want to create about your favorite team or you
want to hear about your favorite TV show or just about science or asking
questions about science,
ask science,
amazing sub.
All of these things exist because we knew this has to be a platform.
Just like Twitter as a platform for individuals.
This would be a platform for communities.
It's just amazing that it's been able to be pulled off the way it is.
The vote up vote down system is such a brilliant system because Steve,
you're always going to have noise.
You're always gonna have people that just want to make noise.
You're always going to have people that just want to be twats and now you can
sort of at least without censoring sorta just push that to the bottom and it's
not perfect.
I will argue in,
and this is all to credit.
Yeah,
I mean there is no perfect system.
We constantly fight against ring voting,
all that stuff.
But I'm,
Steve built a really smart system with a really smart hotness algorithm and by
the way,
were open source.
So if you want that,
go take it.
It's there.
Um,
and,
and I think it is for what it is,
it's one of the best on the web and I think that's why our content is so good.
It used to be right.
We started with just people linking stuff out.
The first link on reddit fun fact was a submission I made to the Downing Street
memo.
Remember that it was,
it was showing this,
this leaked memo during the run up to the Iraq war,
the English government kind of saying like,
hey,
we're going to drum up some,
you know,
a support here to support America going into this war.
And,
um,
and it was my first submission and it was a link to another.
Was that the proposed false flag event?
Yes.
Well,
the,
the notion being,
we can pull this thing up.
Um,
the notion being,
what is it called again,
down in sterling memo.
And so this was leaked out as basically an indication that the British
government really wanted to help drum up support for the war.
I don't know if how explicit it was.
I don't recall if it was like an explicit like I guess they wouldn't call it a
false flag thing in the memo,
but we're going to do a stunt.
But whenever they have like code words and then the blueberry big bad wolf says,
but this,
this was the first submission or reddit and it wasn't that new at the time,
but I was just thinking like,
Hey,
what if it would be,
if this thing actually worked,
like what would we want reddit to be a place to like find and have people link
to?
And this seemed like the perfect thing,
right?
The Internet enabled some person to put this image of a leaked document online
and share to the world right now massive printing press.
And uh,
but what's crazy is we thought that's how it was going to always be.
Maybe like three years in some user because users are fucking clever.
Um,
linked to a comments page like they knew when they hit submit what the link
would be like if the number of the random number we
will not quite random to sequential number we would generate.
And so they linked to what they effectively do is create a self post,
which is now a feature in the site,
but basically read it only used to let people link out to other sites.
One user hacked it and learned you could just link to itself and create this
amazing comment thread so you wouldn't,
you know when you click on it,
when you do an Ama right,
you're not creating something that links somewhere else.
You're creating something that just creates a reddit comment page.
And what that user did by hacking the site was show that there was a tremendous
value in just saying,
hey,
people have a discussion about whatever it is.
And today I,
I believe it's a little less than half of our like content is actually linking
to read it.
So it's actually,
it's an ama or it's an ask historians post or it's just people talking about
shit.
It's not even linking to other content on the Internet.
And we never could've seen that coming.
Wow,
that's awesome.
And it was just the user being creative,
uh,
basically hacking our site to,
you know,
that that word we need to take back.
We need to take back hat.
It's not get a positive thing.
Yeah.
It's,
you can life hack you and you see this,
right?
You can life how you can,
you can body hack.
You can basically find a,
understand the system so well that you can find an optimal way to use it to your
advantage.
That's it.
That's hacking.
It's not,
it's not the like Angelina Jolie bagging on a keyboard hoodie and like doing
evil.
It can be,
but it's,
it's a much more innocuous word.
Yeah.
It's,
it seems to have weird,
it's kind of combination of meanings.
It's like some people use it in a negative way,
but some people look use it in a positive way.
Like,
dude,
I fucking hack the system.
I got it sound like someone's saying,
I hacked the system.
That's that.
That's,
you know,
that's in a positive way.
But Oh,
these hackers broke into this website and put Dixon everybody's picture.
You know,
like that's how we look at it.
And we also have this weird sort of connection to adolescents,
like adolescent prankster hacking being some sort of an adolescent prankster
type behavior,
which I don't think it's fair either.
You know what it is and that's it.
That's an interesting point.
There are,
there's definitely the,
there's uh,
there was a,
so there was always been a spirit of like pranking in the hacker community.
I'm talking,
Oh,
like,
oh gee,
hackers like MIT building in early,
like Steve Wasniak be an example.
Um,
and I think what's cool is there's that childlike wonder like,
because I think a lot of that shit usually gets beaten out of us as we get
older,
especially in a lot of traditional industries and whatnot.
And so I'd like to believe that that can even like be an excuse for people to
think about stuff a little differently and think about stuff a little more.
Like,
let's face takes,
take things less seriously as part of that broader cultural,
no,
it's cool that there's a prankster type thing rather than an evil vicious mean
type thing.
You know,
like when they hacked someone's and they put a smiley face on the front page
instead of,
that's kind of funny.
It's kind of funny,
you know?
Well,
when now we know that someone can hack into your page.
I mean in,
in a way it's probably good that you know that that's possible.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't encourage people to just go hack it.
Everybody's website because it fucks up that person's Day.
But all in all,
overall
you should be lucky that someone's doing that and that if they're doing it,
hopefully they're not stealing your credit card information and doing it
maliciously.
There's a whole,
I mean there we can,
I can dig into this.
There's the,
so there's the white,
so they're like the white hat hacker is the quintessential like,
Hey,
I found out there's a problem with your of website.
I'm not going to exploit it.
I'm just telling you so you need to fix it or hire me.
And it fixes bug,
but usually just like,
and we had,
we've had white hat hackers,
um,
periodically emailing us with exploits on reddit that have done us a huge
service because they told us about this thing we could,
I mean,
you can't possibly know every,
no,
you can can't,
you know,
it's interesting man.
It's,
it's the,
the amount of information that's available now has got it's so,
it's so the world is so wired that it's like
we're standing in this crazy river of ideas that are just constantly flying by
us and a few people are looking around and poking their head up out of the water
and just looking at each other going,
Holy Shit.
And the,
the Internet is where it all sort of pools together.
I mean that's the channel for it all.
And that's where it all pulls together in places like reddit or places like
Twitter all over where you just,
you think about how much you know now,
how many things you've been exposed to now,
how many strange bits of information,
all the chaos that was caused by wikileaks and Edward Snowden and all this
stuff.
Where's all this coming from?
Well,
it's all on the Internet.
The Internet is it just boom,
booms like these shots are being fired,
these holes are being exploded into the system.
And then,
you know,
there's a bunch of scrambling to try to put scaffolding up where the whole
wasn't.
Boom.
Another hole gets blown out of the fucking society standards.
It is weird.
It is,
is probably a really scary time to be an incumbent.
Uh Oh yeah.
But it's a great time to be an upstart.
It's a great time.
They'll be someone who is trying to find a way to get their ideas to the world
because there's never been a better time and yeah,
there's never been a better time to be an honest politician.
It's a good,
good move.
And that's,
that's just it.
Right.
That brings us like,
I god,
I hope we get there because we need to,
I'm a big fan of the states and evolve.
I really do.
It's just gonna take a lot.
It's just going to take a lot of these old fucks getting out of office.
These people that have been doing it in a sneaky,
dirty,
underhanded way since the jump.
You know what I mean?
There's fucking people in office that were alive when Kennedy was assassinated
and they were there like in government and they're still,
they're still involved in something that was supposed to be a career.
Uh,
pretty sure.
Pretty sure the founding fathers didn't want it to be a career that was the
exact opposite of that.
That's one of the reasons why they wanted to put term limits and wanted to make
sure that
they don't get too much of a stranglehold on how things operate because men just
do that and men are creepy fucks when we get power.
Some of us that get to positions of power like that,
they just distort things to their advantage.
And then you're stuck with lobbyists and you're stuck with these Arlin Spector
type and who,
who's also involved in a single bullet theory.
He's one of those long term.
Yeah.
Really?
He was the guy who came up with the idea.
He was the like when people say the single bullet theory,
you know you're looking at it all wrong.
Arlen Specter motherfucker,
that guy,
that guy came up with it.
That's how goofy that fucking idea was.
One bullet went through two people and caused all this fucking damage in their
body and barely like barely dented the bullet.
The bullet.
It looked beautiful little pieces of bullet in their bodies.
Nothing missing from the bullet,
whatever,
whatever.
This is a magic bullet.
This is a single bullet is that Arlen Specter guy.
It was his idea.
He had to come up with a reason why one bullet had done so much damage.
People right now that are anti Kennedy conspiracies theorists are going nuts
right now possibly even on Reddit Rogan central Fulcan route toward with this
boot theory
but that all came from Ireland Specter.
That all came from that sort of old school politician.
Those guys that had just been around and been a part of the system for just two
long.
I wonder if it's possible to do to to,
I mean,
I want to,
I want to be hopeful enough to think that there is a chance for someone to get
into it for the right reasons and then be able to stay in it for the right
reasons there is,
and not get
a lot of,
um,
prompt.
I mean,
fuck guys,
guys like Arland spectrum sharp probably got into it for all the right reasons,
but I think there's certain systems that once you get into,
you just look around and you go,
oh,
fuck.
Like it's just such a mess.
I'll viper's nest that.
You're like,
what?
When you're a young guy,
it's like,
did you see the movie a wolf of Wall Street?
Of course.
Yeah.
Well,
there's,
I don't know how much of that was a hustle.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
whenever you have a story and the guy who it's his life,
it's based on a story,
it's probably going to make them look a little bit nicer than he was.
A little bit more innocent in the beginning of the movie.
But it's that system where you see Leonardo Dicaprio,
he starts out,
he's a family man,
he's a nice guy.
He drinks water,
he doesn't want to have anything to do with drugs.
And he gets co opted by the Matthew mcconaughey mcconaughey,
hey character.
And then he becomes a part of this system that's fucked up.
And so he's a victim.
He becomes a,
someone that you can sort of sympathize with.
You know,
how much of that is,
is real.
Yeah.
That's,
I,
I definitely,
I can only imagine,
uh,
cause you got to figure,
I mean why someone gets into that whole industry.
Actually the whole finance industry just blows my mind because I really like,
I really like making things and doing things and I just can't even wrap my head
around getting into work every day and just hustling like that.
Well,
it's a crazy way to live.
Those guys are maniacs.
A guy used to know that I grew up with,
he,
uh,
became a stockbroker and he was,
um,
he was a maniac.
He was a maniac.
And all of a sudden he's like,
Bro,
we're fucking selling stocks and shit.
It's great.
It's amazing.
He,
I saw him in a bar,
we're going to a suit with a time like,
what the fuck are you doing with a suit on?
He was an animal,
this guy and all of a sudden he was a stockbroker.
They'll like maniacs,
a lot of them.
Wild,
crazy
gambling,
risking maniacs.
I think if you had a job in a system like that,
and I'm not equating politicians with,
with,
uh,
these kind of guys with a stockbroker's,
but I think what a system that's equally fucked,
the political system is equally fucked as a financial system.
You look at the both of them,
you're like,
wait,
wait.
Why?
Why are you doing it like that?
What does that a derivative is?
What is it?
Fuck,
oh no,
what did you guys make?
You're making things up,
but did you mate,
you have $100 billion.
You don't have any money.
There's no money here at all because it's crazy that that system is equally fuck
to the political system.
Like,
wait,
the,
wait the fucking,
hold on a second.
The supreme court just changed the limits.
They just made it so that you can just unload money on politicians,
citizens United.
Uh,
yeah,
I got a nice little jump site.
Okay.
What crazy.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
So I think equal system,
once you incorporate yourself into it,
like a lot of these politicians who probably do go into it with good intentions,
I think you find along the ways that if you try to buck the system completely,
you probably get blackballed.
There's probably going to be a lot of blow back against you by your party,
by competing parties.
You're going to,
you're going to be in a tough situation,
you against the world.
And that's how they survive.
They survive by sort of attacking each other like this and then propping up
these individual candidates that differ only slightly from each other and all of
them supported by the same giant hood of money that comes from corporations.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy system.
So if you're a young guy and you're a senator from Delaware and you decide that
you want to make some changes in this world,
and if you elect me,
I'm going to about bla and boo boo.
And then he'd get in there and you're like,
oh fuck,
you're making me really optimistic right now.
Joe and I,
and I just got,
I got off my house of cards bender,
which,
you know,
those systems are inherently corrupting.
That's what I'm saying.
I just think that younger people have to it,
it almost has to be like transparency involved in your actions is going to reach
such a tipping point.
Oh yeah.
That there will be no room for corruption.
And once that happens,
different stories.
Yeah.
And it's kind of beyond the way there.
Right.
We all,
all the,
the forces certainly seem to be on their way.
I mean,
it's crazy.
We still live in an age where these senators and Congress people are still doing
what they're doing on there.
And,
uh,
Twitter direct messages or,
I mean,
sending Dick Pics,
Yo.
But the funny thing is there's this kind of like,
okay,
at a certain point there'll be a mutually assured destruction where like,
the president is going to have like photos of herself from like a party in high
school.
Right.
We're going to get to a certain point where everyone's got shit on everyone from
all this stuff we did ever.
But that,
that's going to take a little while.
And in the meantime,
I mean,
I hope that the,
the,
the thing that still makes me hopeful is coming back to the sort of finance side
of things.
Um,
money is the corrupting influence in Washington,
one of the biggest,
and,
and right now there are a few people who can put in a lot of money and having a
lot of an effect.
What I hope the Internet can do,
and we've started seeing this happen,
is,
is in the same way that it's given a voice to people through social media,
we can start using small amounts of money and in aggregate started having a
really big impact.
And we saw as we've seen these money bombs before in Oh eight and in 12 but I
feel like the software is going to keep getting better and better with
crowdfunding and with these models that are going to really inspire people to
want to give to a candidate and know that there's actually going to be
accountability too with how that's spent and who they are and whatnot.
One of the big ones,
one of the really big ones that people think is kind of frivolous,
especially people who don't smoke marijuana is the legalization of it and the
legalization of marijuana and in Washington state and Colorado is fucking
gigantic.
Yeah.
Those impacts that it's had on their economy.
It's been so big that there's,
everyone's forced to step back and go,
wait a minute,
wall.
Okay.
All right,
so now we know Eddie hands rubbing on their pants and a lot of late night
meetings and a lot of guys pacing back and forth.
A lot of people yelling,
John,
they're going to smoke pot.
Okay,
they're gonna fucking smoking.
No matter what.
What are we doing here?
Let's make some money.
We cannot,
we can't fix the street.
We can't hire new teachers.
Well,
and that's the,
and that's right.
If,
if,
uh,
if that money being used in the Oregon's drugs were being used for more
productive things and we did legalize,
my goodness,
the war against drugs is just a farce.
Crazy idea.
It's a crazy term.
It's like the war against breathing,
you know,
we figured out drugs,
it's probably made,
it made people better in a million different ways.
The idea that you've got a war against it as this and it just,
you're calling it drugs.
You don't make any distinction.
The war against negative lethal drugs that are addictive,
you're not going to make it any distinctions is just the war against drugs.
Somebody got to break in the fucking store and steal the aspirin at gunpoint.
Like,
what does this war you're saying?
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
It's preposterous.
And I hope the,
uh,
I know dcs,
I don't know where DC is that right now,
is that it was on the table.
Maryland just decriminalized.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
Step in the right direction.
And I mean,
what happens?
Like,
what happens if we get legal weed in the district of Columbia?
Now I know they're not technically a state because that's ridiculous,
but it will happen.
It has to.
But like the point,
you know,
I like,
I see the discrepancy between the federal law and the state laws,
but like if you're not having feds knocking down doors and the district of
Columbia,
like,
you know,
I think maybe everyone's in agreement here and you see so many,
so many x law enforcement's so many ex DEA people come out in support of
legalization because they read the goal.
If we have a common goal here,
um,
to actually make our streets safer and actually curb the,
the criminal element that comes in with this,
um,
legalization is the way to do it and make a lot of money and help help a lot of
people live better lives because they don't have to be treated like criminals
for a drug like marijuana.
I've never seen a single person that I didn't think was just trolling say that
they think that marijuana should stay illegal.
Anyone worth having a conversation with?
Like when I hear Ann Coulter say it,
I'm like,
this bitch is trolling.
She's trolls.
Trolls too.
Good at it.
Obvious troll is out half a fucking smile while she's doing it.
Yeah.
Did you just meme it,
good
thing that came out of places like Reddit is means met Reddit and message
boards.
These dreams,
I mean there are obviously a four Chan is still a hub for a lot of that meme
creation.
I feel like,
I feel like at this point hub,
right?
Yes.
And that's where it all began.
Isn't it a way?
It is.
I mean it is one of the war map scores and that's a classic for Chia.
That picture.
Yeah,
that's a classic fortunate picture.
It,
uh,
and it's,
it's,
it's just,
it's so interesting because now there are enough basically,
right.
10 years ago,
the culture,
people who were spending a lot of time communicating on a forms online was
pretty small.
And now,
right.
Everyone's taking their selfies.
Like it has reached a point where,
uh,
it's nearly,
it's so,
so ubiquitous,
are so close to it.
They,
yeah,
these,
these memes,
these funny,
interesting image,
Mac,
whatever they are can catch hold and literally millions of people can see it.
I mean it gets a little weird when you see like Rick Astley in the Thanksgiving
Day parade a couple of years ago.
Rick Rolling a little,
that's like a little weird little art influencing life and it's change way.
Yeah.
That was weird man.
The Rick Roll.
It's a strange thing with something just catches on like a virus,
like a real disease and spreads across,
I mean,
or an organism almost like a thing with a lifespan.
We like as,
I mean as humans we are,
and I'm not,
I'm not saying plagiarism here,
but like we are sort of intrinsically copy machines and that like early man,
right.
Sees someone else hunting a little better than him and he's like,
oh,
I could use that as a weapon dude.
This guy,
this guy over here,
let's all make weapons.
Right?
And we are really good at seeing what someone is doing it.
That's how we learn.
Yes.
And,
and what's so wild is,
you know,
because of that hyper connectivity,
because of how fast these ideas now spread,
right?
These memes,
like humans are naturally really good at this,
but now we can spread this shit faster than ever before.
Right?
It within hours,
million within minutes,
millions of people can see and interesting photo of a cat or an interesting
video or what have you.
You know,
Alexis,
you can't do that on your own.
You didn't get there on your own.
I think what Obama was trying to say when he was trying to say that,
uh,
you didn't build that,
you didn't make that and he's,
you know,
the about the infrastructure that's required to build your own small business
member was that speech that he was so criticized from there was that that quote
was,
it was definitely taken out of context.
The reality is it was,
he,
he said it very poorly,
but it's essentially what we're saying is we all needed someone before us to
come up with all these ideas that we all pee back,
shoulders of giants,
man.
And I everybody,
look,
dude,
I mean I,
I have been incredibly fortunate,
right?
I sold my company when I was 23 years old.
All right,
that is crazy.
Crazy dude.
How much coke did you do?
Don't lie.
I have actually never done coke.
Good for you.
If you were hanging out with that guy and it was done coke,
you would add too much coke and you'd be,
I'd ask you that question.
You'd go,
wow,
bad things.
Weird eyebrow hair.
You can't like when did that start
growing coke?
It's not,
I am,
I feel like caffeine is enough of a stimulant for me.
Um,
that I'm more interested in the stuff that calms me down.
Yeah.
Chills me out,
chills me out.
And that's what I think would change.
And I think that's one of the things that is changing right now in,
in America because of the fact that the spread of this stuff,
the,
what the spread is starting out first of all,
information wise,
when people found out the real truth about,
look,
the LD 50 rates,
like you can't die from it.
Like it's not possible.
And that Malarkey document or film reefer madness.
Oh,
it's great.
It's great to watch now.
Fascinating.
Oh yeah.
It's um,
that's a,
that's a fascinating movie.
It's fun to watch today,
but just a lot of people that still believe that it does something negative,
that it slows you down or removes motivation.
I think,
um,
people have to realize like the motivation for motivation in the first place.
Like why,
why is that so inspiring to you?
I'm like,
what is,
what is motivation?
You want someone to get off their ass and get a job and get to work.
Well,
they just have to be excited about something.
You know,
the most likely they're more excited about sitting on the couch and whatever it
is they're being exposed to in their life,
it doesn't mean that marijuana removes motivation means that if you're one of
those lazy bitches that doesn't think outside the box and you're stuck in a spot
and your discontent and you like to get high and sit on the couch,
she probably going to be like that for the rest of your life.
But that's okay too.
Is it is a,
it's not harming anyone except those are the same people that would drink cough
syrup.
It would drink fucking crops here up until they,
you know,
their liver failed syrup.
[inaudible] Syrup.
I mean for real.
That is the same.
They're the same people.
And the idea that it did the,
all the benefits reported by people like I'm not saying you smoke a little weed,
what I'm saying,
probably smoke a little weed or me or anyone else who does that.
That's,
that's all discounted.
Yeah.
And not to mention,
I mean seriously on it from a medical standpoint,
I mean you can't fight like every day there's another story from another person
who's using it to get through chemo or using it to get their app.
Like when you see that many people's lives being so positively affected by the
thing that's naturally occurring,
like really it,
come on guys,
it's all,
it's truly unbelievable story.
The fact that it's still around in 2014 was really a truly unbelievable story
because if you looked at it logically and factually and said,
could you imagine a culture in which information is sent instantaneously all
over the globe,
to which the answer to virtually any question a person can come up with can be
answered on your phone in a matter of seconds,
that you truly have the information,
the current information of the world at your disposal.
Could you imagine that there would be one of the most beneficial plants that
grows easily contains essentially amino acids.
It's very high in protein.
It can make you think about things differently.
It can make food taste better.
It makes sex feel better.
It makes you sleep easier.
It removes anxiety,
it makes you nicer and kinder.
The sounds amazing.
You would go,
yeah,
but it's illegal and it's a schedule one drug and the record screeches and
you're like,
wait,
hold on.
What do you use?
This was used to be,
this was a major help,
was a major crop for the 13 colonies.
Yeah.
I'm like,
well,
when they figured out the cotton gin,
that's when things got a little weirder because um,
they used to make clothes with him.
But before the 1930s,
1930s,
they came up with a thing called the decorticator and the decorticator was,
it was for the first time they could use this giant machine to break down the
hemp fiber because before they use slavery and then when slavery was abolished
and the cotton gin was invented all along,
sort of in the same timeframe,
the,
the shift went to cotton and a way from from him.
It's really kind of fascinating.
This is like Wikipedia.
I know a few things that I've seen in documentaries,
but it's a fascinating,
fascinating story because one,
what was really Schwittt shutdown marijuana is the crop hemp.
That's what shut it down.
And that's the main reason why today,
like when I was talking about on it,
we can't grow our own hemp.
We would love to,
we would love to pay a farmer to grow hemp for our protein powder.
That way.
We could monitor the soil,
we could make sure everything's organic.
We can do all the right steps,
but we can't do it.
We can't.
We literally can't do it in America.
Land of the free,
but it's,
it's totally non psychoactive.
That's what's so stupid.
Like it's,
it doesn't what you're getting when you're getting like a hemp bag or are you
getting hemp protein powder?
This is a zero THC in there.
It's not in there.
Not smoke kids.
You cannot smoke your handbag.
Don't try and do it.
But the idea that that somehow in other can be illegal because it's related.
It's crazy.
I mean that's like a poppy plant.
Like you could have a poppy plant,
you can eat a Bagel were bananas.
It's crazy.
And then you know what it is though.
Here's the real victims of ending the drug war would be all those prisons that
would no longer be full of young black men.
You say this,
but what if your business is running prisoners,
right?
What if your business is prison guards?
I mean,
that's another thing.
When someone think of the prison,
the prison industrial complex prison guards lobby against drug legalization is
they do it because they want to stay in office.
They want to keep their jobs and how many lives has to be ruined in the process.
It's fucking crazy.
It's a vampire system,
so horrible van system and it's a system that's brought out of,
it's based on these reverberations are these vibrations from the past.
It's all like the scramble when people were retarded when they came over on
boats and this is just how they did things and throw in a jail.
He'll fucking scoundrel you were smoking marijuana or whatever.
The rule that you broke is that they realize that they can do it so they do do
it and they throw you in some fucking cage in 2014 the fact that's still going
on and that people are actually profiting from it.
This is,
these are more things that the Internet has a huge fucking problem with because
the Internet is guys like you is young fellas that are very and unconventional
and seeing the system and being like,
you know what?
I don't buy it.
I think a,
there's shit that people I knew growing up that were adults,
I knew there were fucking idiots and they do,
they made bad choices and now I'm looking at the,
the repercussions of this everywhere I'm looking at an item saying,
no,
this is dumb,
this is,
so this is one of the things,
especially talking to college students that I love bringing up,
which is that,
and I'm the first to admit like I have no fucking clue what I'm doing 99% of the
time,
especially when I got started,
I still don't know.
And I've,
I've come to realize like I don't,
I've got,
I've got been lucky enough to meet some pretty like successful,
impressive people.
But like you think going to the surface,
we're all just hacking it.
Like we're all just fake expertise,
experience,
those things all help.
But like every one of us is a fallible human.
All the conventions and rules and status quo we know were created by other
fallible humans.
And there's no reason not to look at that and go,
Huh,
does it have to be that way?
Or why is it that way?
And if the reason why is that's the way it is.
Well,
that's a terrible reason,
you know?
And,
and when you see the world as being that hackable,
so to speak,
like you start to realize,
all right,
well let's just,
let's actually question stuff.
And,
and for,
you know,
I remember I was a freshman at Uva when nine 11 happened for this generation of
millennials coming up.
We,
we mow nearly all of us.
One of our first really vivid memories of the world was nine 11 this awful
tragedy.
And then we get into these two wars and then think of all the authority figures
we've had in our life since that moment.
They've all at one point other either misled us,
this sort of deceived us.
You've got the financial crisis,
you've got the housing bubble,
all these conventions.
Oh,
trust us,
we know what we're doing.
This is the thing,
the American dream is buying a home,
go to college,
take on that student loan debt.
Don't worry,
there's a job waiting for you.
Every single one these conventions from,
from all these people in power have not held up.
And so I think in particular millennials,
millennials look at that very skeptically cause we were like,
all right,
you know what?
So the conventional stuff didn't work out for anything.
Like we have no choice but to realize,
you know what,
we're all just hacking it.
So let's,
let's really,
let's dive into the passion.
Let's,
let's figure out a better way to do something.
Not Settle for the way they've always been.
I think you're completely right.
And I think,
um,
first of all,
I'm slightly annoyed by this new statement and I'm first to absorb millennials.
I know it's terrible for you.
I'm sorry.
Not Sorry.
I'm not buying.
We can rebrand this.
I think we should.
I really do because I think there's a divisiveness or there's a separation that
comes when you start labeling people by like what era they were born in.
It's a,
it's a state of mind more than it is.
Yeah,
I think so,
but I think it's horseshit generation x generation y to fuck up.
It's just human.
It's like this,
this idea of putting things in a label generalization.
The human race is evolving.
Watch father knows best and then watch game of Thrones.
Okay,
shit's different now.
We don't have to come up with names for the generations and your generation y
and there was fucking Jamie from the laugh factory.
Tried to tell my friend,
uh,
Todd Parker.
Todd Parker's a standup comic that I started out with.
Jamie was like,
buddy,
you have to be generation x guy.
This
is what you do.
You go on stage and everything.
My generation,
generation x,
think that's going to be your hook.
And I remember him trying to explain it to change it.
I'm in the background going,
don't fuck it.
Did you hear what he told Tony to do?
What he tell you must always wear a cowboy hat.
It just look like woody from toy
cause he needed the hat shopping for that.
Jamie,
the guy who owns Jamie Masada,
the guy who owns the laugh factor is a sweetheart of a guy.
He is a very nice guy.
I love him to death,
but he's crazy and he gives advice to comedians and he was a comedian one point
in time.
He might've been the second or third worst comedian that's ever walked the face
of the earth,
but as a club owner,
he's like one of the best.
He's a sweetheart of a guy.
He wasn't the worst comedian.
He just,
we sit second or third,
barely speaks English and he's not funny,
but he's a sweetheart of a guy,
but his ideas are terrible and he'll like tell young comedians,
so like pull you aside buddy.
Listen,
this is your move from here on out.
You go on stage.
You were a superhero costume with Falcon who don't look like stupid,
you know,
that's the joke.
I want to know.
Is there a comic somewhere who actually took his advice?
Oh yeah,
there's been a bunch.
There's a bunch.
I want to main name any names because it's sort of like someone who got tricked
by a guy who said he was in the military,
so they had sex with them and then it turns out it was just a liar and the girl
feels bad.
I don't want to shame anybody.
I won't say any names,
but yeah,
there were some comedians for sure.
There was definitely some comedians at listened and changed their,
their persona,
you know,
and came up with like a,
a plan and none.
It never worked because once jammies got you dancing,
first of all keep,
no,
I couldn't throw the dance body.
You're dancing bad.
It's not my dance moves are good.
Mitzi did it also with Carlos been it's,
he made,
um,
well,
I mean,
I dunno,
I dunno mean allegedly it was mrs idea,
but obviously we're not pals with that dude,
so we probably shouldn't tell his life story without checking in with him.
He probably doesn't even know it.
This soilage.
Yeah,
well I don't hate the guy,
just hate what he's doing.
But there's been a lot of those club owners that come up.
The best club owners are like Wendy from Denver who just stands back.
She's,
you know,
if you're doing well,
you're doing well.
She encourages originality and her clubs are built like a real scene in Denver
just because of her.
Like if there's one person that like is important for the,
the,
the entire Denver comedy scenes.
Just One lady,
Wendy.
Mitzi ever give you any advice that you either took or
do have SEO Dardy you're too dirty.
It's clearly,
clearly too sick.
What you said was sick.
It wasn't fine.
It was sick.
I used to have this bit about Anna Nicole Smith's husband.
This is the one she always hated on.
Unfortunately,
there's no good versions of it online.
I think it was an audio version we're going to do.
It's recorded now,
but it was a,
um,
it was all about him making do ugly things before,
before he died like that.
She was earning this money and then everybody's like,
oh,
she's stealing his money.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
The guy made $1 billion from scratch.
Don't only thing he knows what the fuck is going on.
Like he's,
he was,
he was onto it.
Yeah.
So the joke was that he was going out in style with this big Fat Kentucky Fried
Hooker and he was just,
I mean it was just this horrendous old man,
young,
you know,
buxom blonde bit.
That just was so disgusting.
And Mitzi would go,
he gets to Scott's Dang.
It's not funny.
I'm like,
but why is everybody laughing?
And there's fucking idiots.
You clearly don't have to.
I mean,
this is like,
Hey,
it's nice advice.
But like,
if people are still laughing and buying drinks,
she's going to keep having you.
Well,
she'd loved me,
you know,
she's nice.
She's a sweet woman.
She just didn't like,
it wasn't her style of comedy.
You know,
I,
I get it.
I get that.
And there's some things that I did that she really loved and she wanted me to
keep doing those.
And I love those too.
But there's shit that I'll do that I,
I,
and I always have because I would laugh at it and my friends who are comics
would laugh at it.
Like I like if I know that Stan hope is in the room,
I'll probably ramp something up just cause I know he's the,
I'll,
you know,
add some extra fucked up shit to it just to get him to laugh.
Just,
just so some delight appropriate that I don't even mean,
but I'll do it just for standup if he's in the room,
like we do that to each other.
Comics do that.
So when,
when a comic is writing a bit that's like really fucked up,
like half of it.
It's just like to make your own jaded sense of comedy,
like jolted,
you know,
just get a little fun.
Yeah.
Just see,
oh man,
that's,
I uh,
that is the bar that I like cause I do a fair bit of public speaking.
Right.
But,
um,
I don't have to fucking tell jokes like that stand up bar has to be,
and I'm not just blowing smoke,
like it's gotta be the hardest like public speaking Gig to have to do.
It isn't,
it isn't,
but to do it night after night to well that it actually makes it easier.
Joey Diaz says it best.
Joey Diaz is,
he goes,
this is the easiest,
hardest thing you can do.
Okay.
It's the easiest,
hardest thing you can do because if you do it right,
it's easy.
If you got it down and not in the beginning,
God damn,
it takes a long time to not be on shaky legs every time you go on stage.
But once you get good enough to where you kind of like,
you understand yourself better,
so he's not as insecure,
you're not as concerned about acceptance and you can kind of relax and you're
more comfortable in your own skin and then you kind of understand the roots of
humor better as you get older and then you become a comic.
So then boom,
you're a comic.
Um,
and I think from there it's all just about maintaining.
It's about continuing to do it.
And once you do that,
it's fairly easy.
It's like once you're doing that,
but it's like once the train is moving downhill,
it's going well,
but if the train stops and you've got to get it up hill,
oh,
you're fucked.
That's why guys,
when they take time off,
something weird happens to comedians when they take like three years off of
comedy and then get back in because they're,
their prospects are slim.
Those are some dark sets that you watch.
You can see the bottom of a man's soul.
You see some shit,
man,
because they forgot how to do comedy.
I mean,
they just fucking forgot how to do comedy.
That happens after a couple of weeks though,
sometimes two weeks off and I went back on stage.
It was like,
Oh shit.
Why do I feel nervous right now?
Simon?
Tension.
I mean,
you don't really prepare that much and you don't listen to recordings.
And I do.
So every I tape every single women.
Oh yeah.
Usually it's on the way to the next gig.
I'll listen to that.
That's a good one way to,
but one way that I like is to sit down and listen with a notepad and write down
shit I shouldn't do anymore or write down shit.
That's the front end is clunky and it works over here and I'll just keep doing
that.
This guys,
I'm glad you do do that.
The guys who don't do that are really silly.
Like it's,
it's an important point.
I have to do it
as a high fraction all down and then have to write it out on the note cards and
stuff.
That's a good move to if as far as memory,
that's the best way.
Writing things out physically in long hand or I write it down on my galaxy.
I got this fucking galaxy.
Where is it?
How dare I left it out there somewhere,
Mike.
The galaxy note three is big as well.
I've got an ogre hands so it's perfect.
I have a note three too.
Um,
but it is outside.
Yeah.
Um,
but they are there.
They have that little note,
the stylus.
Right on my notes longhand.
They're both schools.
So instead of,
I'm using it like,
like instead of having a notepad,
but I always still have no pen anyway cause there's still,
for whatever reason I haven't let go of the nipple.
But the um,
the notes written notes on that are almost just as good.
I mean really,
it's very sensitive.
I'm a stylist skeptic.
Are you really?
I am.
I've never,
I've,
I talked to him real quick.
I'll grew up the phone.
I want to see if you fuck with it if you like it.
I mean I had like,
I've just never,
I have no three.
I just have never,
like I pulled it out and I was like,
Nah,
you have the pebble.
Have you tried the yes,
the gears or whatever the watches.
I don't want it from Samsung.
Don't even get me started.
The thing is,
uh,
and here's the thing.
I had the first pebble there,
y Combinator company.
I've,
I actually was,
I was sitting in the room when we interviewed them.
I remember their first prototype and I was so blown away cause he's like,
here's some friendly Canadians.
I made a cool watch.
All right,
I'll talk to my phone if there was a blackberry back then.
And uh,
and then they launched that campaign and I was like,
this is amazeballs,
right?
10 million on a Kickstarter.
I preordered mine and I got my watch and I was really impressed,
but I was a little like,
I liked it,
I didn't love it.
I'd be wearing other watches back and forth once I got this one though.
Seriously,
like game over every day.
Really the fatal flaw that Samsung Watch aside from it doesn't play with Ios.
The fatal flaw is the battery life.
It's got a beautiful full color screen.
It lasts for maybe a day.
And like I got enough shit to charge every night.
Like I don't want to also have to charge my watch every single night or it
should have a builtin a charging mat or something that where you just take it
off and think about the new one.
The gear to that just is supposedly better.
It looks interesting.
I,
you know,
and obviously like I said,
I'm buddies with the pebble guys,
right?
Um,
so take this with a grain of salt,
but in all objectivity,
I think it's an amazing,
the software,
the Ios,
android obviously know they know what the fuck they're doing.
The question is going to be the hardware.
Um,
if that,
I mean that watches all just Photoshop right now,
right.
If they can make a watch that has a decent battery life that looks that good.
Okay.
All right.
I'm perking up but until I actually see something with a real battery on it,
I forget about Google glass just announced that Google glass,
it's going to be available for one day only to anybody.
And of course CNN uses the photo of the most hipster,
hipster
sweat.
This look at this.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
those are all my house.
There's a joke notes.
She Damn,
I love this though.
It's pretty bad ass man.
But this is really encouraging.
I there,
there are,
um,
I really,
I don't know.
I want to think like,
I feel like I'm still just as hungry as I was when I got started and I'm really
motivated and inspired.
Like,
cause I feel like if you want to stay on top of your game,
this is the stuff you have to do.
Cause as soon as you start getting soft and start getting cocky or complacent,
man.
Right on that.
All right.
Let's see.
I'll save it and I'll put it up as a Twitter message.
All right.
Okay.
It's fascinating because a,
it,
it doesn't,
it doesn't lack,
like there's not anything where I'm doing it where I'm like this isn't
completely picking up what I'm,
what I'm writing.
They picks it up.
Exactly.
As long as the stylist is touching the screen,
it's perfect.
And so for like writing notes,
I'm in their small file so you can,
you know,
you'd have fucking thousands of these things that backs up automatically.
I get an email when it backs up.
Hmm.
Hello.
I literally never taken the stylus.
You can suck it.
Apple until you come up with one of those,
you can suck it.
But I,
I remember jobs used to be very anti stylist.
Fuck jobs.
You can suck it too.
I'll dig you up and then you can suck it.
That was rude.
There it goes.
Saved.
I didn't mean it.
If I managed to do the new information that's coming out about the two new
iPhones that come out this year,
it's,
you know what I heard,
I heard 'em they're gonna make you gay?
No,
no.
Oh,
I heard that.
look at that.
Oh,
this is for the updates for the votes votes.
Okay.
I can,
and I can send this right now.
Just throw it up as an Instagram
set in the future.
Pebble works with the iPhone and what information isn't sent it does it send
texts or he's kind of basic stuff.
You get notifications.
Um,
you know,
you can mess with your iTunes if you want advance,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
and there's a whole fear,
I think the long play and it seems like a smart one is the APP store model.
So pebble has their APP store and there are tons of different apps.
So I can check in on foursquare from my watch.
I don't have to be that guy who takes out his phone
squared.
All right.
This is one thing that's whack about android.
When you use the Instagram APP,
it gives you this weird little,
no one's going to to see this,
but it gives you a weird little window.
Oh,
they won't let,
you can't get your whole hallway.
That's wack as fuck.
Well see that was a great demo.
But see that's,
that's one way that the um,
the iPhone it over this,
no,
no.
That,
that the square ratio size is just an Instagram thing.
You have to use a different program,
like a,
what's it called?
Uh,
should be,
it'll just add black space so that you should be able to shrink it though at tip
on the iPhone as you turn it sideways.
So it's the,
the wrong,
you know,
like when you have a picture of the wrong way and then you take a screenshot of
that.
So it keeps the black bars on the side and then,
yeah,
then you have less protein going to do a gangster.
That was a pro tip tip by brown rice cropping.
So,
just as for,
if you can get for the up votes and then the reddit alien,
that'll suffice.
See what we can do that.
And I'm looking out for you.
No,
we're going to have to do another one.
I have failed you just,
no you haven't,
you know.
No,
I feel like I'm letting everyone down here.
Just do a smaller one.
We'll do one more,
but yeah,
Google glass for $1,500.
So Google glass.
Um,
so I'm 1500 bucks.
Are you going to throw into the trash a week later?
Yeah.
Going to be,
look at the fuck is wrong with me.
I am very,
very skeptical.
I don't think it'll,
I don't think it'll hit mainstream adoption.
I think even if they go,
I mean they've got designers now designing glasses.
They got NBA players wearing them so it doesn't have that thing.
So I think,
so I am full disclosure,
I'm an investor in a Google glass,
but,
but here's the reason why.
Um,
they actually just had a bunch of press and the club,
um,
the,
they are,
they are building software specifically for industries.
So like they're working with doctors at Beth Israel who can use them to check
in,
folks get their records with,
cause they need both their hands free right there working with energy companies
so that people out in the field can have real time data on what's going on at
this random oil pump.
Like if they got a check settings or updates.
Basically they're targeting specific industries where people need both their
hands free.
And so it's not the sort of obnoxious like walking around on the street,
uh,
ordering your latte from your face.
It's like this is a very specific task where I need both my hands free and this
is helpful.
And so I think,
I think that's where it'll succeed.
Kind of like how segways or just for mall cops.
I think this'll be next.
Horrible useful.
Oh God,
yes.
That's right.
Can't forget the tourists.
It's going to go a blank on that one yet.
You haven't gotten one.
It'll change your rate.
They're really dope.
He's just being facetious.
That was like one of the things that they were saying about the,
uh,
the product before it came out.
That was going to change cities.
Change your lives.
Life as we know it though.
Streets around it.
You silly bitches.
That was the most ridiculous thing ever.
You're just standing and moving.
How's that change in life?
Did you hear about the new electronic,
our age of a cow tipping that's going on in San Francisco and stuff like that.
People are flipping those little baby electric cars.
Smart cars.
Smart smart card tipping.
Yeah,
that's it is.
Fuck.
Wow.
Imagine if you went outside and you,
you're a girl and you weigh a hundred pounds.
That's a dick.
Move fast.
I also think I,
so I grew up in the suburbs.
I did not see a lot of cows.
I guess just time to time,
but like you,
can you actually tip a cow
a no.
Yes,
yes.
No,
no,
no.
We've done it.
Just wants you to save it.
You'll never tip.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
We did.
Columbus,
Ohio.
Me and my friends did it twice.
You've done it right?
Was it like a calf?
Was it like one of those calves too?
Just saying.
So what happens is that when the cows and the cows are in the fields,
they pretty much locked their legs and sleep standing up a lot.
That's how I sleep.
And so you just go next to him and push him and they'd just fall the heavy?
No,
they,
they just tip right over keeping cow tipping site.
This was stuff that suburban kids know like,
or that like is an urban lore because none of us ever hung out with cows.
Oh,
if you ever want to go cow tipping,
I'll take it.
I mean,
that was good.
I don't think that they would really like that,
but no,
they don't like it at all.
I wouldn't like it.
Did you really go cow tipping Brian Weiss?
Yeah.
Twice.
Can you find you actually video actually pushed the cow over believe it.
Yeah,
me too.
My friends.
Okay.
And I want it to be one of those,
remember those night vision like the Paris Hilton videos.
I want it to be one of those night vision videos of the cow and coming over.
All right.
Do you have a,
um,
an Instagram?
I do.
It's,
it's my name.
Just add Alexis Ohanian or Ohio neon.
Okay.
That's another thing that's annoying about these things is that they insist on
trying to change what you wrote there.
Like my creative,
the ethnic,
uh,
yeah.
There,
I'm not gonna take it personally.
It's just that they're their auto correct is like really aggressive.
He's color away and goofy.
Yeah,
they're awake.
Yeah.
Well then good luck.
They're going to kill you.
I see nothing.
How's Tim got to look at these videos before you put them online,
Bro.
Seriously.
Find something real.
Yeah.
You can do that often,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
He might have thought he was cow tipping mushrooms.
Tripping his balls off.
Dude.
We tip cat cows,
but we never left the house,
man.
What are you talking about?
We were in the field.
You never remember.
I was there.
I was tipping cows.
Yeah,
I bet.
If we Snopes tipping cows like Snopes,
Snopes,
cow tipping,
I feel I should have brought my laptop also.
Side Note,
uh,
and I've been,
I've enjoyed your podcast died.
I love how I love the real time with the laptops.
Uh,
I wish,
I wish every show basically had someone in real time just calling out shit.
Here we go.
Ready?
All right,
let's get this out of the way.
Cow Tipping at least as popularly imagined,
does not exist.
Drunk man.
Do not on any regular basis sneaking in cow pastures and put a hard shoulder to
a cow.
Taking a standing snooze does tipping the poor animal over.
While in the history of the world,
there have surely been a few unlucky cow shoved to the side by boozed up morons.
We feel confident in saying that this happens at a rate roughly equivalent to
the Chicago cubs winning the world series.
Okay.
This is,
um,
got snooped cows.
Cows like
sit down in like on their legs and just sit there and you can go right up to him
and tip them right over.
This is a,
from a modern farmer.com.
Well,
I'm convinced article on cow tipping.
I've subscribed modern front of her for a decade now and I,
they have never led me astray.
Youtube,
the largest clearinghouse of human stupidity the world has ever known where you
can watch hours of kids taking the cinnamon challenge.
Teens jumping off route to rooftops on the trampolines and the explosive results
of fireworks set off.
Indoors fails to deliver one single actual cow tipping video.
All right,
well we did it as a kid.
The one exception is a Russian dash cam video,
which shows a semi truck full of cattle overturning.
That's really good.
You need to watch it was shaking themselves off and walking away.
How's not giving a fuck?
Yeah.
Wow.
This is a spectacular dash.
So this uh,
this article is called bullshit on you,
Brian.
When I was younger,
we would go to these farms in a,
in planes plain city,
Ohio and they would have tons of cows and we would break into the cows,
smoke weed and there'd be cows that we break into the cows,
no break into the fence.
And there would be cows that would sit there like on there,
like perched up like on there like legs,
like it's just sitting there.
Sleeping would come over.
Just push them right over.
I don't know if that's the cow tipping that you've heard everybody doing like
people saying that the cows tip over.
But that's what we used to do.
Cause that's what we thought you were supposed to do.
I don't understand what you just said.
This cows are standing up right?
Cause they stand up when they sleep,
right?
No,
not all the time there.
There's cows like knee thing here.
I'll show you.
Okay.
I thought cal was always stood out.
Horses always stand up,
right?
I have no idea.
I'm going to my guts telling me horses are the ones.
Yeah.
Horses I think always stand up.
Right.
And if they're down to hurt,
we have the Google.
Yeah.
Um,
but I'm,
I'm really settled this cow tipping.
Sorry.
We have the Internet disagrees with you.
Oh look at that.
That's a
brown cows tell rolling.
That would be like that.
And you just push it.
But there'd be tons of cows and it'll be night at timing will be drunk.
And that's what we used to,
I don't know.
That seems to be cow tipping
anybody that's cow tipping.
They're just lying down cows.
So you're going to send the email to Snopes saying,
well actually you're wrong.
Well,
I have a feeling the problem with calling bullshit,
if you didn't grow up in that environment,
you might truly believe that it is bullshit.
But then if a guy like Brian actually grew up there and actually pushed over
some cows,
take this to your fan base,
they would sit like this and then you just go over there and just push him over
and they would roll over and wake up and freak out and it would be scary and you
would run away.
Now cow tipping.
What I think they're saying is not true is actually tipping over at cal.
It's like completely standing up.
Maybe,
well maybe that's what people have in their head,
but what it really is is what you're talking about.
That's when we did it.
We just did,
cause we heard people did it and then we were like,
let's do it.
There's tons of here.
Brian Redman move.
I heard of the people who are doing it and I'm like,
well this show alive.
Fuck it.
So then cow tipping is real.
I guess if I would say,
well yeah,
at cal rolling,
I'm gonna call it cal rolling.
Rolling
cow tipping as an a cow standing up and you pushing it over.
That doesn't exist.
But that's probably not what cow tipping ever was unless they do sleep standing
up because sleep standing up.
Okay,
we need tons of pictures of cows doing exactly how.
Yeah,
but did they also sleep standing up?
I should have say,
let me just say how much I appreciate you guys get into the bottom of this.
We need to,
we should.
Worst case.
How far are we from some cows?
Oh,
not that far.
We can get to 100 an hour.
Okay.
Does a cow sleep standing?
Common misconception that cows don't lie down.
Hmm.
Why?
Cows may doze off for a few minutes at a time while standing up.
They typically lie down to sleep or simply to rest.
Okay.
I'm calling bullshit on the people calling bullshit.
I think Brian's right.
I think Brian is right.
He went cow tipping and that's how you really couch it because when everybody
says is that cows are sleeping and he'd go up and push him.
Well obviously if that's not true,
if they only take a little nap standing up and usually they sleep lying down and
then their whole premise sucks because they don't understand what cow tipping
is.
Yeah.
Cow Tipping starts from the knees.
Like Jujitsu class.
Like if you take wrestling class,
you start standing up for the most part,
there's a room full of 50 dudes trying to double egg each other.
That shit gets really dangerous.
So jujitsu classes all start from the knees.
So real cow tipping like the idea of it doesn't exist because that's like
wrestling style.
Everybody starts from their feet.
But Jiu Jitsu style when you're already on the ground,
that's real.
This is great.
Now whenever I drive past a bunch of cows will be thinking about Jujitsu.
I'll just what I do.
That's the vision.
That's my gift.
You should,
um,
you should totally sell snow to go fuck themselves.
The craziest thing is that modern farmer incorporate or whatever it is,
how scary it was.
I just remember it.
No,
because I'd be scared.
I wouldn't go.
We we did,
I remember twice but only reimburse size first time,
scared the fuck out of you and then you're like,
listen,
I can do it wrong.
And the reason why it's because one of the,
we used to hang out with this bridge where we would drink and under age and it
was just like everyone would go to this bridge in the middle of nowhere and
there was all these farms around it and that's why we'd go there.
Cause there was no police,
there's no one could even know you were there.
You see you can have bonfires and all this shit like that.
So then after he got wasted,
everything kind of laid around and all the fields and one of the fields,
his cows,
and it was pitch black because it was in the middle of the country.
So it was just stars and you see shadows of cows and so you would like sneak up
going up to these cows.
He didn't have cell phones for lights or anything like that.
So it was literally just lighters and shit.
And you just go up and just push it real fast and then we'll go through and you
just run away and it was the scariest shit ever.
Wow.
And you'd be stoked.
Did you ever find mushrooms on uh,
cow patties?
Yeah.
But back then you just didn't think about that.
And like I didn't get into mushrooms too.
I was in college,
well Dunkin went to school in Asheville,
North Carolina.
And when I went up there,
I understand Dunkin
so much more after visiting Asheville cause it's just a hippie Mecca.
And they were getting [inaudible] apparently the mushroom flora or whatever it
is,
the spores are so healthy up there this because it rains a lot and there's so
many of them that they had to start giving the cows some sort of an antifungal
diet to kill the mushrooms because so many core harvesting.
Meanwhile,
I'll probably make the kids sick cause a few mushrooms probably grow on some
poor poison psilocybin.
I mean you want to talk about missing the fucking point,
right?
Poisoning cow shit.
So that the most beautiful thing that God ever created can't grow there.
You fucking dummies.
But he said that they would constantly go there and just pluck them off and just
eat them.
They were everywhere and just trip balls and the whole town,
it's so psychedelic,
like partially because of that.
The whole town is like Asheville,
North Carolina is it trippy fucking place.
I feel like I need to visit now.
You got to visit.
It's awesome.
It's really cool.
Everybody's walking around like they have a main area where like bars and
restaurants are,
and people just walking around like everybody's walking around and it's like a
small town that exists in a giant world,
but they're modern.
So it's,
it's uh,
I fucked up.
I shouldn't have told you guys about it and it's going to ruin Asheville.
They the,
but I kind of understand Dunkin way more now after going to this town.
It's like,
oh,
I see.
Like you,
you were spawned and one of the most awesome environments on earth.
Like this place is fucking sweet.
What,
what did they call it when they went out on an expedition?
I wonder [inaudible] out tip.
Do you want to go like candy picking them?
Harvesting as some kind of,
let's go get shrooms.
It's
so dangerous though because I remember even as a kid just going up and eating
berries cause I was like,
oh look berries and I would just start kicking Ferris.
Wow.
You know?
And then like you find out
a hundred years ago you would never survived.
There's no way you would've been dead before you were fired.
Yeah.
But you're fucking,
what's that honeysuckle shit like?
I used to eat a lot of plant because there was nothing to do.
So you look what's that purple stuff or you pull it out,
just suck on it has nothing to do.
Yeah.
So we just eat grass.
I would eat a few things.
You know what I found out that tastes good actually is dandelions like Dandelion
Greens,
make salads at a Dandelion Greens.
My grandmother used to make them and I went over to the house once and she had
this dandy line sal and I was like,
what is that?
And I was like,
that's dandy lines and they were like,
it's really good for you.
It's edible to my aunt,
my uncle telling me it was good for me I think is what convinced me.
But then I found out that it's like a common vegetable that a lot of people eat.
T am I crazy?
It makes you out of it.
I believe you can.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's actually good like as a salad it's,
it's a good tasting green and pretty fucking good for you too.
What's not to like,
I don't know how we got on sandy line business.
I don't know how
we got onto the dandy.
We've covered a lot of grants on this.
Yeah.
I'm not a planner.
Freak ECO friendly.
It makes the world go round my friend.
Yeah.
And you know what else makes the world go round.
People know what the fuck they're talking about.
That's why this cow tipping thing,
it's really pissing me off because I believe we've got to change.
I think cow tipping is some real shit and I think this is something that arts
here is smart card tipping change to this woman.
Columbus Smart car tipping has hit Columbus,
Ohio.
Wow,
that's so stupid.
It's totally rude.
It's easy to do.
I bet though I bet like three or four guys could probably push well those things
over pretty easy.
How much they weigh.
It can't be more than like 1500 pounds.
Right.
I still,
I still flinch whenever I watch the,
uh,
the youtube videos of the crash tests in those things because they are more
resilient than you'd expect.
But,
but I would not want to be in one at a top speed.
Anything is in a top speed.
Um,
there's a guy who used to fight in the UFC,
Matt Grice,
and he got rear ended.
Someone was going like 60 miles an hour and his car was parked and uh,
and he,
he didn't even get hit by anything.
Just the impact of the car.
He had to have brain surgery and they to remove a plate on the top of his head
off for this one,
see this one here,
and then put it and then connect it back on and ended his UFC career.
It's,
you know,
the guy had been,
it had been in like all these crazy fights,
like really action packed wars in a car accident.
Took him,
I got up and he's sitting in a parked car.
Yup.
Shit.
Boom.
You see that thing?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It does actually stay and actually,
wow.
That's incredible.
It looks pretty good.
Our slow look at that.
You're still dead.
Uh,
not maybe.
Maybe you bitch.
Maybe I'll be fine bro.
You'll walk away and I'll jerk off on the call.
Man.
I saw,
I saw the guide mini Cooper crash the other day.
It freaked me out because they're small.
They're small.
I mean,
no matter what,
they're small.
Just the,
uh,
the thing that happened on the highway,
it's like everybody's worst nightmare.
The Fedex truck crashed into a school bus filled with high school kids.
Oh yeah.
Horrible Northern California yesterday.
It was in northern California.
North,
mid California somewhere,
but it was on the five,
which is kind of a sketchy freeway.
And apparently she said giant collision nine people dead,
like one of those horrible fire situations.
I am,
I am firmly in the self driving car camp.
Um,
I am,
I am ready car.
Well or any,
I mean there's,
there's a company coming up right now,
there,
there are a few people working on this.
Um,
but I am just ready for robots.
Me Look 90.
That's a new main bro.
I'm ready for robots,
but I'm ready for the robots.
And so they enslave us.
But 95% of our flights,
our robot,
the message,
obviously there are fewer things they hit in the sky,
but like we trust robots with a lot.
And,
and when it comes to the self driving cars,
I've gotten a ride in one for a minute.
Um,
and we're getting there,
but like there are so many senseless deaths,
so much senseless bullshit happens because
of human error behind the wheel of a fucking thing.
That weighs a lot.
That's totally true.
But will you long for freedom?
One of the things that I've been thinking about when we were talking about,
you're saying like,
oh,
I wish I was,
I'm jealous.
These kids that are born today,
I don't buy it because I,
I'm very,
I think that I'm very,
very fortunate to have been born in a time where the Internet didn't exist to
grow,
to be a young man without it and then experience it once.
I've kind of,
when I understand myself and the world a little bit better and got to see two
different worlds,
get to see the world pre internet and got to see the world post Internet.
The people that are growing up just post Internet,
like there's,
there's a certain,
there's a certain something we're all gonna Miss.
We're all gonna miss just getting on a motorcycle and driving on the highway
because eventually that's going to be illegal.
It's going to be illegal to be in a fast car.
It's going to be illegal to do anything with.
It propels you on your own.
I mean,
but if you look at like what's going on with technology,
if you look at like the idea of self driving cars a certain point in time,
what's the justification for letting someone drive their own car if their ratio
of car crashes is even 10% higher?
I mean as long as,
okay,
here's the thing,
humans are infinitely resourceful.
Like I think,
I imagine it looking like cruise control for a while.
We're like the self driving,
you'll still be sitting there,
he'll be chilling but like it's in cruise control and then if any point you can
just hit the brake or start driving,
tick heads would just start doing that and weaving in that traffic and you'd be
right back to the one on one again,
it'd be the same fucking animal over and over again.
Well come on Bro.
There were bits of that,
but it's still not as bad as like if it's 1% of the people doing it,
which is,
I think it's still be pretty high.
But like then you still have 99% of them being efficient robot cars I think
without the sending to you know,
into the future.
The hope is though humans are resourceful.
Even if you had it mandated where every car was was just,
it only knew how to self drive.
Someone would hack it.
Someone would figure out a way to get a wheel on there.
Someone like I sense a class war.
I said,
oh well that's a whole nother story.
But it's coming.
The highway flooded with the self driving cars and other people like standing up
while they're driving their continental convertible screaming at the top of
their lungs at the robots.
The robot,
people taking lawnmowers or the high way fucked up it's tractors while they're
dealing with four wheels and while there's a robot,
the whole,
the whole thing is bizarre.
It's going to happen.
I mean the technology that's invaded our lives so far become a part of our life
so far.
It's not stopping anytime soon.
And I will say this,
I am.
I think so.
Yeah.
I got to,
I mean,
I knew a little bit of the pre Internet world and I'm still jealous,
but I will have,
you know,
I'll have my own transition or this is all a process,
right?
The,
the,
the generation coming up,
we'll take the Internet for granted.
They'll have that.
But like,
um,
there is inevitably going to be something else that displaces them and blows
their minds.
Maybe it's like the Gatica babies situation.
Um,
I think we're already at a point now where we can better understand
a human DNA.
It's the point where it's like,
all right,
it's not unreasonable to imagine a world where like,
hey,
if you don't want this genetic disorder,
like we can make sure your kid doesn't have that.
Most people would probably be like,
yeah,
man.
And you don't want to be the first guy to say yeah to that.
No,
but you could,
I mean,
this is all pretty reasonable here.
Um,
and you imagine,
okay,
well let's say that happens.
Then it's like,
all right,
well we've gotten rid of like,
okay,
Parkinson's,
whatever.
And like everyone,
most people are pretty happy about that.
Um,
but then it's like,
well,
if you can do that,
do you want your kid to have blue eyes?
Like we can do that too.
It's just really easy.
Do you want a blue ivy?
And then you very quickly started seeing the,
the Gatica scenario start playing out and um,
and these are going to be really interesting and,
and,
and serious ethical questions we'll be asking ourselves in terms of like,
I mean,
I generally,
I'm on the side where I'd be very happy if a lot of genetic disorders were w
technology was able to remove those things from happening.
Um,
but at what point does it start crossing the line of us tampering too much and
deciding,
you know,
I don't think there's a line.
I think that's what we're here for.
I really do.
I think the idea of us slowing down innovation for some reason,
like,
cause we're crossing a line that we invented ourselves.
It's ridiculous.
I think there's a pattern and I think if you look at that pattern,
the pattern is constant,
exponential growth of technology and innovation.
And it's a thing that human beings are thirsty for,
were freaking out about the galaxy.
S five came out.
Ooh.
You know,
I mean I was at radio shack yesterday getting into some headphones.
This function,
people that work there,
they're still radio shack shack.
I don't know if radio checks us.
I'm sorry.
Ham Radio Parts online tutorial customers.
But the bottom line is I was there because I needed to get ahead heads,
phone for my,
uh,
my cell phone and uh,
I go,
uh,
I go when does that,
cause I knew it was out.
Like sometime this week I go,
what does that galaxy has five hours it out today or tomorrow?
This guy,
first thing I was off,
I'm going to get it before you do.
Really?
Ooh.
Wow.
That's the thing.
Like everybody wants to have it first
given name up to 1100 stores.
No radio shack.
I got my first job as a copy.
You,
I say,
uh,
I was not sad about seeing them close though.
I was,
I was at 13,
13,
14 year old pudgy kid who was demoing video games and why it was mostly like
computer hardware in the middle of a comp USA.
Um,
for like every 30 minutes I'd have to get on the headset microphone with a big
TV behind me demo,
like Madeline's like language learning software and I'd have the same routine
for like 15 minutes every 30 minutes.
And like literally no one would be watching.
And here I am,
this like teenager going through puberty and I've got people,
people would walk up to me and be like,
no one's listening,
kid.
Just stop.
No one's listening.
And it's like,
oh,
I don't play me for hating me.
But it was great because it got all of my public speaking fears out of the way
because I spent two years being ignored,
uh,
every,
every 30 minutes.
That seems like a really good way.
Actually it was,
I was getting paid for it.
The company I technically work for was called [inaudible],
s I.
D e a,
but they were
one of the casualties of the tech boom.
That seems like a really good idea to like if you wanted to alleviate your fear,
put yourself in one of the most uncomfortable situations and get numb to it
through.
Yes.
APPS and people ask me,
oh well you know,
cause tech,
there are some,
there are some very good public speakers and tack,
but they're,
you know,
the common stereotype is that they're not.
And so a lot of people ask like,
oh,
how'd you get good at this?
And I said,
cause I did a ton,
my first job was getting paid to just do it while going through puberty.
So if you want to get good at it,
just do it 10,000 hours.
Right.
Just just get up,
get awkward,
get in front of people and embarrass yourself.
That's fascinating.
That job probably pilot really played a pivotal role in your life.
Dude.
Real talk.
I have the card,
I still have the business card from Carlos,
who's the guy who hired me.
It's idea.
Um,
cause he was the first guy gave me a shot.
I wonder if he's Carlos,
this idea,
if you're watching created this monster.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's an important thing,
man.
Sometimes things will happen to you when you're young,
when you know you're,
you think it's just a shit job.
But it really is some weird life lesson.
Dude did too.
I always tell people,
fuck getting an MBA.
I got a job doing public speaking as a teenager,
being embarrassed routinely.
And then my next job was in the service industry and I waited tables and cooked
at pizza hut and,
and like series like that will teach you the show much about entrepreneurship.
Right?
Cause at the end of the day,
you were on the front lines for you.
I mean,
your pay is coming from that tip.
And it's a matter of balancing,
you know,
satisfying the customer.
The customer's not always right,
but almost always right.
And uh,
and just,
and,
and dealing with it and solving problems with other humans.
And if you can make,
if you can bridge that gap of like empathy,
man,
I tell you that every single day as an entrepreneur,
every single day.
Absolutely.
And he and also I think the shitty jobs that you have when you're growing up
inspire you to not want to have shitty jobs.
Yes.
I worked with my friend Jim drew,
my pal Jimmy lawless.
I worked with him for like two weeks.
One summer he was a carpenter and I was like,
uh,
he was a,
he graduated a year ahead of me and he had like always had his eyes on doing
carpentry.
I was just looking for like a Labor Gig for the summer.
But within two weeks,
I don't even think I lasted two weeks.
It was fucking brutal.
We were building a knights of Columbus Wheelchair Ramp,
so in Knights of Columbus Hall,
so the entire day,
every day was spent carrying bags of cement and pressure treated lumber.
She's just huge wheelchair ramp.
So just bag after bag of cement,
just carrying these fucking bag poem,
carrying these logs.
Poem.
That was the whole day.
And by the end of the day,
you were dead.
You couldn't do anything.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't last.
I wouldn't last three hours.
I lasted like two weeks,
but I used to think about it forever.
I would think about that Gig and I'd be like,
that's what it's like when you doing something that you don't want to be
knowing.
It's unbelievably difficult.
That's the life and that would like motivate me to get things done.
If I never had that Gig,
I probably wouldn't know how hard a job can suck.
I really wouldn't know.
That's the truth man.
That's what that should be.
I don't know if there there's like,
but that is,
that is top flight advice for any especially cause like I know those of us
supposed to get into tech.
It's a hot industry right now.
Right?
There's more money than ever going into it.
Making a lot of people rich.
There are a lot of kids coming out of college who want to be the next CSEC or
the next to whoever they want to be.
Mexican know commsec is suck.
You want to be the next duck rolls.
So Cobell was like,
cause you know him.
So go back.
That's how were you guys when you're young?
We,
I've met him once or twice,
but we're not,
we're not friends.
I mean,
I'm not saying that we're not like there's no,
I'm,
I live in New York.
I'm not,
I'm not in the silicon valley world.
I dabbled,
but I just,
I just visit.
Right,
I hear Ya.
That's probably the best way to be because then you would start talking like a
one of those west coast ticky.
Yes.
And so it's over annunciating so that is,
that's the problem I think for a lot.
I think I,
I'm just getting a sense,
and I'm generalizing here,
but I think a lot of the kids right now who are trying to get into that,
um,
maybe never had that job,
maybe never had that bit of perspective that I think has helped me a ton.
Tremendous.
I think it's obviously helped lots of people over many,
many centuries to just understand,
get to get a bit of sense.
I mean,
even,
I know I live in a bubble now.
I,
as much as I wish I didn't,
I know I to some extent live in a bubble,
but I still try to keep that perspective as best I can,
which is hard.
But,
um,
it's the fact,
and look what you're talking about that at skilled labor,
like speaking of things like with the robots,
skilled labor is something that's still like when robots can do that,
they will enslave us.
So it's those jobs or what I'm trying to say is,
are going to be really their fundamental already,
but they're only going to continue to be important because humans have to do
them and they are Shitty,
hard work.
But we don't have enough people.
I don't,
Mike Rowe has a really good campaign actually for getting more young people
interested in the trades because there is a huge demand for welders,
for carbon and for all,
for all these people because we don't have a generation coming up now that knows
how to do this stuff.
I mean,
I can barely put together Ikea furniture myself.
And I'm lucky because I'm good with like a laptop.
But,
um,
it's a real need and it's hard to fucking work.
Well not only that,
I mean doing carpentry,
like building a house,
it's really kind of fun.
Building a house is very rewarding if you're a guy that has developed,
like I grew up,
my dad and my step dad was an architect and so I grew up around a lot of work
developers and a lot of construction guys.
I got to see the pride that they take when they've completed a job and built a
building that they design.
They all worked together on this.
It's,
it's cool thing.
It's a cool thing to see and watch and you know,
the fact that that's sort of like a dwindling part of,
you know,
what kids are looking to do and tomorrow's age,
it's kind of sad.
So problem.
It is a problem,
but it's kind of sad.
I mean there's always going to be people that appreciate it though.
There's always going to be someone that builds an awesome log house that's in
demand cabin porn.
I think that's actually a website.
Don't say it out loud unless you're affiliated.
No,
but like I hope actually,
I don't know.
I'm trying to remember what Mike Rowe's organization is called,
but it's it,
it's trying to push a for that and I took him around.
I am the guy who is also telling people like,
learn how to code if you want the super power for this century.
It's learning how to code.
That takes a lot of time.
Jamie and I were talking about that yesterday.
Too much work.
Sorry.
Well,
uh,
I guess you're,
I guess you're not going to be a mark Zuckerberg,
Joe.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not going to be a CSEC.
I'm not coding.
It's not happening yet.
It also like if someone else did what I did,
it would be a harrowing experience.
They wouldn't enjoy it,
you know?
And if I did what they did,
it's different strokes for different folks and my friend.
Yes,
indeed.
When you look at the future,
when you see what's happened just in the short amount of time that red it's been
around,
you see what happens.
And you know the time,
the,
your first computer when you were on were you on AOL,
which was a little late.
Uh,
it was an ISP.
Compuserve.
Oh you have a regular ice 33,
six.
I was a little late.
Oh really?
Late.
It was my first month at a 14,
four,
1414 I remember 56 k blew my fucking mind.
This can't be real easy.
And then it was like dual line 56 K so you could get like two 56 case together
and share bandwidth,
insanity,
all the stuff you could download it.
When you look at that and you look at the future,
do you think the future is going to be in some sort of a,
like a,
an implant or some smaller and smaller device that lets you interface with the
web?
I,
I hope it's not too invasive.
I mean there's already there,
right there already people living that kind of Cyborg lifestyle.
Now we've seen the transhuman community.
Like it's,
you know,
the,
the basic levels,
just quantified self and like having a thing that counts your steps but like,
or Google glass.
But you know,
there are next level,
it's all theirs,
but their next level,
I mean there really is a trans human community of people who have,
you know,
cybernetic i's who have,
um,
you know,
cybernetic guys.
There's a filmmaker,
a Canadian filmmaker actually who's got,
he lost an eye and a shooting accident,
replaced it.
Um,
and,
and you know,
as a filmmaker,
it actually,
at least he argues,
helped him with his craft.
Wow.
There,
you know,
people who have lost limbs.
One of the things that actually really intrigued me about the world is that,
you know,
you have people who have lost limbs,
for instance,
were born without them.
And replacement limb technology basically hasn't changed at all.
Like it's,
it's the same civil war,
revolutionary war replacement up until very,
very recently.
It's basically just like,
here's a stick.
Um,
and there's been so much innovation on the last couple of decades to help with
limb replacement,
right,
where you can actually move digits on fingers based on impulses from your
armpit.
You obviously there's the blade runner.
Um,
and,
and to see the improvements on,
uh,
on,
on feet where you can actually run faster on these artificial limbs than on the
real ones.
Like it's,
there are people who are
living through this right now because of how the were because of whether they
were born this way or some injury that happened.
Um,
but you're also seeing people who are deciding to enhance themselves,
um,
through this technology,
this bionic.
I think it's freaking me the fuck out.
This is a,
uh,
apparently I don't think they have a completely bionic eye,
but they have chips that they've installed in eyes.
Yeah,
he's,
I,
you had the filmmakers,
I can't remember the name.
Uh,
they've figured out what I saw.
I don't think it's a totally fake.
I think what,
unless it's a totally different story,
is that live science,
what does it say?
Robot madness.
Human Becomes Eyeborg rob spend.
Say One I'd filmmaker holds up a prosthetic eye in the Camry.
Hopes to fit.
He can fit inside.
And I don't know how the old that article is,
but I,
oh,
from 2009,
nevermind.
But,
um,
but he's been doing a lot of work in this area and meeting a bunch of,
you know,
fellow cyborgs all over the world talking about this.
And I'm like,
there's a transhuman subreddit.
If you go to r slash trans human,
there's an entire community of people,
hundreds of thousands who were talking about all of this.
Here's the article about him that's really recent for March 21st and it says a
colorblind,
it says call Lou or in the English way of announcing,
this is why we had that revolution.
Colorblind artists becomes world's first I Borg.
An artist is born literally colorblind,
is able to hear different colors through an eye,
Borg and Tena that he has now had implanted into the back of his head.
Whoa.
Just for colors,
just for colors.
It's just colorblind.
He's not even line 31 year old near Harbison that this guy really wants to get
callers from camp.
How will we know if he's seeing them,
if he doesn't never seen him before.
Holly know what the fuck that is,
maybe thinks it's collars and you're like,
can I borrow your eyes?
Bitch.
You don't see color fucking shitty as eyes back.
It's like people who were trying to convince you that the first droids were were
good too.
It's just like an iPhone.
Okay,
let me,
let me try and make a text message and why is it,
why does it vibrate when I touch?
You can't talk Shit Outta here.
It until you touched it.
Blackberry with the fucking push button.
Screen Click,
click.
Do you remember that?
I had a blackberry for a minute and like 2005 2006 but I,
that was,
well they were not bad at the time doing great.
But there was a blackberry attempted an iPhone like device.
Do you remember that?
Oh it was deaf touch or something like something like that.
I think that's exactly what it was.
Oh,
poor dog shoe.
Soon guys too soon had that number and you had to go to a website and then type
in the number just to see like a very small photo.
Tiny ass little thing.
Yeah.
So this guys,
I mean he's crazy as fuck because he can see and so just to get colors,
but this is the artist color blind artist or there's a a,
there's a,
it's just
if a filmmaker who just lost an eye,
oh they see all this is happening.
All of this is to say,
I think we are,
we're approaching a point where these technologies basically the Internet,
uh,
have a much more seamless interaction with us.
But uh,
we just think a little while still got,
it's still got a little bit.
Yeah.
Um,
but whatever and enjoy this moment because when it hits,
it's going to be so fucking weird when,
when,
when the singularity does take place,
which I personally think he's going to be some sort of an artificial creation,
whether it's a artificial intelligence or a network that can think for itself
essentially on my matrix work.
Yeah.
One of those things is going to happen and it's going to be a motherfucker,
man.
It's going to be a,
it's going to be a complete flipping of the board table.
No,
it's what I like about Kurzweil and the whole singularity push is they are
optimistic.
A futurist.
There are definitely a lot of futurists who are just going to read their real
downers.
Um,
but the Kurzweil one is a pretty,
uh,
pretty positive one and dude,
who wouldn't,
I mean the,
the crazy thing is right,
if we have enough processing power,
all right,
okay.
If life is just perception,
write a little thing that goes,
again,
not a scientist.
Um,
but it's things that fire that make us feel like we're perceiving this world of
that sandwich or that beer or whatever.
Like if you have enough processing power to reproduce the human brain,
how can we actually tell the difference?
I mean,
if at the end of the day it's doing all the same things,
right?
That's it.
We're just perceiving a world.
Uh,
it really starts the question like consciousness in humanity and all kinds of
really big awesome things.
Absolutely.
What is humanity and is it just the standards that we've accepted?
Because this is what we're accustomed to and this is our culture.
And so we just,
we don't want to change things or in the face of some overwhelming intelligent
life that we've created ourselves.
It literally becomes God's around us.
We're going to have some weird decisions to make as to what should we keep
fucking,
these guys are way better than us and they come back to class and they couldn't
save us once.
I mean,
this is,
this is getting real now.
I don't want to worry.
You guys know much about skynet.
Don't,
don't,
I mean,
don't worry about it.
Scare the shit out of us.
No,
it's,
these are,
I mean,
I don't have answers to this stuff.
Um,
I've got a front row seat and it's been fascinating.
that's one of the things I'm,
so y Combinator was the VC from the seed stage,
VC firm,
the first invested in me and Steve like nine years ago.
And I work as a sort of advisor,
an ambassador for them these days.
But like the companies that come through there,
like,
I mean,
yeah,
me and Steve got through with reddit.
I think if we'd applied today we would just been laughed at.
What do you mean apply the Co if we'd applied today with what we did nine years
ago,
we would have been laughed out of the room because the,
the applications,
the quality,
the richness,
how much they've created and how far they've come.
It's so much further along.
And so we're,
you know,
companies like Airbnb and Dropbox for instance also went through y Combinator,
multibillion dollar companies that started the same way we did just a couple of
founders and pizza and working and um,
and we're seeing companies now that are doing like there's a self driving car
company.
I went through the last batch there,
there are a couple of engineers were who have outfitted their Audi with a self
driving car.
It looks like a,
the thing on top of the police car.
It looks like one of those things and it's just all the sensors and um,
they can do highway driving in this Audi,
you can actually like sit in this thing while it drives into this a self driving
car.
The three engineers have been hacking on for the last six months.
Like,
it's just,
it's it,
you can just drop your jaw and be like,
Holy Shit.
Like this is,
this is a wild future that is being created right before our eyes by,
you know,
people just like me and things like the Google glass,
which I think is just a step along the way.
It's gap.
The gap has to be bridged.
I mean,
it's not going to be bridged in one instant application.
That's a,
an injection of nanoparticles into your body that allows to you to interface
your,
you know,
your retina and your visual Cortex with the worldwide web is distributed through
government Wifi.
I mean,
that's probably a hundred years from now or whatever it is 10 years from now.
Who knows how things get crazy you probably next week.
But the,
the Google glass is the bridge.
I mean,
it has to be,
there's gotta be a Google glass and there's gotta be a Google contact lens and
then there's gotta be something else and it's,
it's going to happen.
Just like we went from the brick phone,
you know,
they were in the rap videos and everybody was balling.
It had that big ass brick phone.
Yeah,
bitch,
I'm talking to you and you ain't no one near me.
Saved by the bell,
Zack Morris phone or the ones that were in the suitcase.
That was another whole interaction with the court.
It was Courtney's phone in a suitcase.
Hello.
I'm walking down the street on the phone.
That's how important I am.
You know?
And people would get real,
real angry and uppity when they would see those.
They didn't like it.
People get upset.
I could see that.
They didn't like it.
Look,
it's fucking,
man.
I saw what?
It's fucking phone coming out of a suitcase you should be using now.
Folfiri,
a home or a,
why don't you go get a job?
Get a fucking job.
You home.
I'll walking around with your phone.
But now it's changed.
It's so small.
I mean,
they're sliding into pockets and you opened them up and they'd fucking show you
the world.
And I think no one who had one of those stupid brick phones ever saw that
common?
No.
No,
definitely not.
And that's a bridge that's been gapped in my lifetime through my memory.
Gets,
uh,
yeah,
and I'm,
I'm 100% aware of when it happened.
I had a really,
I had a cell phone in 1989 at a cell phone in my car.
We'd like a car phone.
Yeah.
I had a car phone.
We would it,
uh,
how would that work and cigarette lighters stuck into the,
into the car?
It was installed in the car itself.
Baller buttons or Claire?
Well,
it was,
it was a girl that I was dating her.
Um,
I wound up buying the car from her and her parents bought her a car,
but she got a standard,
like a stick shift.
She didn't know how to drive.
She hated driving a standard.
And so,
uh,
I was dating her at the time,
so I wound up taking the car and then eventually paying her for it.
But it was like she installed this car phone.
What'd you make?
Would you make to make a habit of taking calls from it?
No,
no,
you can't.
It was stupid,
stupid expensive.
And it was like right after it all happened.
Like we started breaking up so it was like she couldn't even drive the car.
So I drove,
I was driving the car and then I was sending her money for,
it was the whole thing.
It was a disaster.
Okay,
so the lesson learned is never buy a car with a car phone.
Yeah.
Well No.
At the time it was ridiculous thing to have,
but it was pretty crazy.
I don't remember why she wanted again,
why we wound up getting a phone.
No one needed it at the time.
It was only like a few people that even knew that I ever seen with the time.
Yeah.
There's a guy named Jackie Flint,
you know Jackie Flynn is Jackie Flynn's a comic.
He's been in a bunch of the Farrelly brothers movies.
Very funny guy.
He was the first guy that I ever saw that had a car phone and I was like,
this is the craziest fucking thing ever.
This guy can just call people anytime he wants.
It's stupid expensive and it wouldn't work everywhere.
It would like you would drive down the street.
Well,
it wasn't like now,
like it's odd to get shitty service.
Then it was fairly standard,
like most of the time you got shit.
Sorry.
If you're driving,
you're constantly going in and out of services.
You'd pull over to the side of the road and just wait,
oh,
you keep driving it so you got good enough service.
Then immediately pull over.
Yeah,
that was a big one.
Yeah.
Especially if it's an important call.
You can't go over the hump.
You can't to this day can't go over Laurel Canyon.
If you've got something to say,
I can't trust them for sure.
With everybody's phone is going to be a bump in the road.
I'm still,
see,
I'm still still learning about this whole la thing.
The four oh five don't fuck around the four or five when you come over that
hill,
when you're going into the valley,
if you're coming from Santa Monica and you're going over that hill,
prepare for death,
no cell phone coverage,
and you got over that Hump.
I don't know why they can't fix that.
You know,
it's,
there's two 20 it's 21st century.
Not only that,
they're building a 19 lane highway up there.
I mean the highway is fucking enormous.
It's the biggest highway you've ever seen in your life.
And I don't know how many lanes it illegal saying they're so big.
I grew up in Boston and the first time I came to California I went to um,
uh,
Bellflower.
I took a ride down to Bellflower,
which is uh,
um,
down down the four or five and to the 91.
But I couldn't believe how big the highway was.
I couldn't believe it.
I was driving,
I was like,
this is insane.
The amount of concrete,
cause all those old Boston highways were all like four lanes,
two up to back.
That's it.
These things were giant,
like multiple lanes,
five,
six,
seven lanes on each side.
So you guys know what you're doing here with the car thing.
Oh that's 20 people.
And that's why self driving cars to change everything I'm telling you.
Is that going to ever be there is purportedly,
I'm a,
I mean I'm in New York guy now,
so like I love by public transportation.
Do you guys is,
is that it's non existence that happen,
isn't there?
I mean I busted it depends where you want to go.
Like I live in Burbank and so there's like a right in north Hollywood,
there's a station he can get take.
It pretty much dropped the car off and go right to the staples center.
So if there was an event at the staple center,
you just go in and out.
But other than that,
the problem is that they don't have it good.
Like
they don't have in Santa Monica,
they don't have it like the beach towns and it's uh,
it's just not as cool.
Like you have to,
it's not good service system.
The also like the city is so spread out,
like California is so spread out and people are not really into the idea of
being in a car with a bunch of other people.
Everybody's so self important on here.
And so nonintegrated it's one of the things that I,
one of the things I was thinking of when,
uh,
I was starting to raise my kids,
I was thinking maybe my kids would probably do better if they lived somewhere
like New York where they kind of had to interface with people all the time on a
regular basis,
a bunch of different strangers all the time.
Whereas like California,
where everybody's like,
we go from one box and to another box and occasionally we see people to step out
of their boxes and then they go in their boxes and we all go our separate way.
Whereas in New York,
everybody sorta like meshing,
bumping in Boston too.
Yeah.
Which less?
Boston would you ever move baggies?
No,
too.
It's too cold.
Wow.
You're just wrong.
Kind of cold.
That wet cold.
Colorado dry cold.
I like the wet cold is ridiculous.
See I,
I was born and raised on the east coast,
man.
I don't know if I could ever,
I could ever give it up.
Oh,
that's so good.
I lived in San Francisco for two minutes.
If it fell into the ocean,
you'd still stay alive.
Stay.
Oh,
you'd figure it out.
Sign away.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but what I'm saying,
yeah.
All right.
But I,
I,
I uh,
I just never,
I dunno.
And there's so much,
obviously there's so much in tech going on in San Francisco and actually at
least tech scene,
not too shabby.
Not too surely.
We'll snapchat's the one everyone talks about right now.
That's all Dick pics fueled by China's tinder's is La as well.
It,
what do you think about snapchat?
I just,
I don't,
I tried using it for a minute,
but I just don't,
does it get to a point that just like every kind of technology do you get to a
certain age that you start not getting it?
Oh,
that's,
maybe that's what that's actually,
that's definitely what it is.
That's what it is.
Cause I,
the college story,
every,
every kid snap chatting,
all the things,
every growing,
no snapchat.
Yeah.
People like it and whatever,
it's fine.
People will look for fun shit to do on their phone,
you know?
And if something comes along,
it gives you a time limit.
On a picture.
There's my asshole,
you know,
do you motherfucker,
you took a screenshot,
he'd let me know.
Yeah,
but I,
it's kind of close to home.
Joseph.
What doesn't have to,
first of all,
you don't.
If people are so stupid,
all you have to do is take a picture of the fucking screen with Hannah.
That's really bad.
So dumb.
It's like it's not,
you don't really need to snapshot it.
There's no,
nothing goes away anymore.
I mean you can't send it to someone and I hope it goes away.
First rule,
assume if it is digital,
it is everywhere.
And then the second rule is as soon as there's a photo of you online somewhere,
someone is Photoshop to dick in your mouth.
And now even more with this new heartbleed exploit that's going on that the
government made,
I mean a hacker made.
Oh that's good.
That's what I was going to ask you.
I forgot what,
what percentage of people on Reddit are government disinformation agents that
are designed to interrupt conversations and turn the tide
on climate control?
Let's say if you go to Reddit,
Reddit,
what?
What the climb like troll arguments are actually one of the,
one
of the subs I don't remember cause every sub red is its own form,
its own community with its own moderators.
One of them actually banned climate deniers.
Like they basically said we're not going to,
and then you know it,
what typically happens is this is like any wordpress blog deciding,
hey,
we're no longer going to post stories about blah.
So if people really want it,
they go and create a new sub.
Right.
And they're like,
fuck you guys were creating real politics or really real politics or whatever it
is.
So it's a,
it's a,
it's a robust enough system that like new things rise.
But so the Bot
band climate deniers from one form,
but the climate deniers can open up
their own forums.
Well basically like creating a subreddit is really like creating a wordpress
blog,
but you're part of a much larger network.
And so every sub reddit,
it has its own moderation team.
Like snoop for instance,
as a moderator of our trees.
That's ridiculous.
Amazing.
Snoop moderates.
Yeah,
he's,
he's active,
quite active.
It is dope.
It's dope.
As it,
yeah,
it's,
it's pretty,
it's pretty spectacular.
But like fresh nose on my nose will,
people can create,
uh,
the,
the sort of forms and these communities and run them as they see fit.
And if people don't like it,
they create another one.
That's amazing.
But on the whole,
we work really,
really,
really hard to mitigate,
um,
sort of ring voting and cheating to try to goose up stories or goose down down.
So I mean,
I'm sure,
you know,
as soon as red it became,
as you know,
200 whatever,
a million people,
as soon as it became as large as it was or at some point it tipped over and
people realized it is in our best interest to be here.
Now there are always there the social media douchebags who are uploading all
their garbage marketing content,
but I'm sure I'd be naive to say that there weren't states trying to help
encourage and some content and discourage others.
But we,
like I said,
we work really hard and I think there's no perfect system.
Um,
but I'm sure people are trying,
but the vast majority of people are just regular people.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
I agree with you.
I think,
um,
there's always gonna be someone who tries to do that,
but you're dealing with the numbers of humans are so great.
It would be really difficult for someone to subvert that system as like a
climate of Stein group trying to intercept ideas and throw disinformation into
them.
There's just so many really smart people out there that can see through
bullshit.
And then we'll post,
you know,
like contradicting information and show what's wrong with this and then spend a
lot of time to make you look stupid.
Yes.
Those guys are good at it,
man.
There's some fucking,
yeah.
Awesome discussions on,
on whether it's on reddit or,
I have a message board that's been around since 1998 aren't here.
No Jima.
No,
exactly.
In this form as a,
like a vbulletin.
It's been around since 2001,
you know.
Um,
and it's not the best system though.
It's a good system.
It's easy to go back and read,
you know,
but it's not the best system as far as like the getting the best stuff to rise
to the top.
It's like the reddit system of vote ups and vote downs.
That's like,
it seems to be like a really good way of eradicating shitty ideas or at least
non,
you know,
non unanimous opinions or opinions that you unanimously voted against.
Do.
Uh,
do you guys know,
check out our Joe Rogan?
I wonder,
I imagine there's an active Joe Rogan.
So yeah,
there's Joburg and experiences,
which I always online.
And then there's a,
here's the Joe Rogan experience,
which is pretty,
pretty good.
There's a,
I think 21,000 people that,
that do it.
Oh snap.
And so subscribers,
you know,
those are like Twitter followers,
right?
So subscribers are about maybe a 10th of the actual people looking because only
about a 10th will be subscribed.
So there's probably about 200,000 so almost a quarter million.
Now.
How do you keep someone from,
like say if someone was a on reddit and they were posting something about an ex
girlfriend or being rude about information photos,
how do you stop that
stuff from happening?
Well,
I mean it depends.
It depends on the situation,
right?
Like reddit as a platform,
like Twitter doesn't actually,
actually,
no,
Twitter does host,
sorry,
so read it.
Read.
It does not host content.
So we,
well I guess we host texts but we don't host images or video.
Um,
so often times those things will be on youtube or imager and that's,
you know,
we're kind of like a traffic sign or like a map to win,
but we can't do anything about the actual content.
Um,
and in the event of,
you know,
content that's posted,
the generally accepted rule is if it is legal,
then we will let it stand.
And that has been,
you know,
it every,
like I said,
every sub,
right.
It gets moderated.
So most the vast majority of them are moderated such that like garbage content
like that,
like on your form,
you wouldn't want a bunch of garbage content floating up like that,
that wasn't adding any value.
And so you have the opportunity to,
you know,
as a moderator bandit.
Um,
but as a general platform,
uh,
the thinking is if it is legal,
we're okay with it.
Um,
even if you know,
in some instances it is distasteful.
The vast lakes of the vast majority of the content is just harmless or good.
It's also,
I feel like with a lot of the distasteful stuff that people were getting really
upset about,
I think that it's one of those things that the human race is just going to have
to go through.
It's like a phase or a stage in this integration with information that we're
going through.
There's still anonymity and the anonymity is something that people cherish and
they cherish their quote unquote privacy and their rights to privacy and they
have all these ideas about it.
But that's,
that's going to be like saying you don't want to see people anymore.
It's really what it's going to be like.
I reserve the right to not see people.
Okay,
well if you go in the woods and go deep,
deep,
deep in the woods where there's no people,
you can not see people.
However,
if you want to be in cities,
you're going to have to see people fuck.
And that's sort of what's going to happen when it comes to people being assholes
online.
It's not going to be as simple as you're hiding behind a duck.
Talk 69,
you know,
that's your name and you're distributing all sorts of nasty evil shit.
And then what did you think about,
here's a good example.
That one guy that he,
he was on reddit and he was like,
apparently he was very rude and put a lot of nasty shit on.
They found out who he was and he got fired from his job and it turned out like
this is a guy,
he's got a family and he had to support them and now he's like been publicly
shamed.
What was your feeling on that?
Um,
well,
which part?
Like,
you know,
what the price you pay for a freedom or for the freedom to post stuff is to
take,
have to take responsibility for it as a content creator.
And uh,
you know,
it's like at the end of the day,
you create the soapbox.
So like we created a kind of soapbox or a printing press or a hammer,
right?
Like any kind of tool.
And so at the end of the day,
we're not responsible for what,
like ultimately someone does with a hammer or a printing press.
The vast majority of which is good sometimes cannot be.
And you know,
he,
he essentially paid the price for that.
Um,
and it's,
it's frustrating because Ah,
I'm the whole,
the vast majority of people who pick up that hammer are,
you know,
like any random Twitter user or any random for any random person,
like just being reasonable,
normal people.
And some of them aren't.
And you know,
it's a,
it's a matter of saying,
you know what,
we want to have this be that open platform.
There's no,
fundamentally,
there's no way to stop or police every single thing that gets done in real time.
Um,
we make our best effort and when on occasion there are things that are illegal
while we do what we need to do.
But um,
well apparently this guy was a real douchebag online just as a real asshole and
rude and so people sort of justified that he could be taken down because of
that.
But in his defense and it's sketchy defense.
Um,
what I would say is that if you,
if the precedent's been set and the precedent is anonymity and there's some
people that get a charge out of using that anonymity to poke at people and be
rude and nasty and they get some weird sort of sick charge out of it.
Okay.
Yes,
they definitely are causing discomfort.
they are definitely probably quote unquote cyber harassing.
But that precedent of anonymity is very strange because once we've established
sort of what we think is going to be the,
the standard reaction to these things,
people are going to get upset.
They're going to ban screen names,
but they're not going to do is find out who you are and then go to your employer
and expose all your shit.
And once that does happen,
it's like,
Whoa,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait.
I thought we were playing a game.
Like he,
he might've gotten out of hand,
but he probably thought at least part of it was him playing this game that was
afforded to him by anonymity and probably what we understand the laws to be.
I think,
uh,
the,
the real,
so,
so one of the things that has is generally accepted is this idea of I'm not the
challenges,
so this is,
this is pseudonymity.
And then he had a pseudonym.
He,
he did not,
or any one of us who goes online to use a pseudonym,
still has some kind of a persona online and they probably use that account
elsewhere.
They,
they do or maybe they don't.
Um,
but there's some acceptance in this new world that like all of you in one can
find out almost anything about sort of public available stuff about us with
enough searching with enough sleuthing on that phone calls and enough tenacity,
right?
Every investigative journalists been doing this forever.
But like there is this challenge that like there is no,
there is no easy answer for this because ultimately there is going to be right,
that's going to show up as a website.
It's going to show up as blobbity Blahs,
real identity.com and some really determined person is going to create that
thing that's going to out whatever it is.
And there aren't very clear laws around this just because it hasn't really,
it happened.
There's no precedent for it.
And,
uh,
and so for the time being,
it becomes,
you know,
try as much as possible to discourage it.
This idea of like quote unquote doxing.
Um,
but there's no other,
they call it docs.
Uh,
I'd actually don't know the etymology of it,
but like to find the documents around,
I presume,
I don't actually know.
Um,
and that's the kind of phrase for it,
but uh,
but it's a matter of figuring that out and I'm not,
I,
I think we are still as a society figuring that out,
um,
because it,
but we like trolls in a way.
Like people like funny trolls.
Like I,
I'd like some trolls on the message board.
I've got some people in my mess where they're just hilarious.
There are,
and it's so tough to draw that distinction because I know what you're talking
about.
It's a kind of a game they're playing and the kind of a game is that trying to
piss people off and they're,
they're trying to get people to argue with them and sometimes they'll argue both
sides,
you know,
they're just there,
they're having fun and they might do it and some people take it real deep.
Just like I was saying that if Stan hope was in the room and I was on stage
talking shit,
I might say something extra fucked up just to make him laugh.
I think they do that with each other as well.
And I'm not saying that it's all innocent,
but I am saying that if you do look at it all honestly and objectively,
you've got to leave room for the entertainment value of people fucking with
people on the Internet because there's something to it.
Yeah.
And there is look and there is a,
there's a,
there's a precedent for this,
right?
In meet space like hecklers for instance,
there is Meat Space as opposed to cyberspace.
Like,
like there's a precedent for this.
And I think there is
and,
and one thing I should stress is that just having a real identity does not stop
people from being assholes on the Internet.
Facebook is a perfect example,
right?
You can have your photo,
your full name,
and trust me,
we've all seen those screenshots.
Maybe we've even seen them on our friends' posts.
But like people say something
full offensive,
horrible stuff and just on Facebook with their name next to it,
like I say some unbelievably dumb shit too.
So,
so having,
having a real id will not people from
being obnoxious or stupid or you know,
whatever adjective.
Well,
I don't think it'll stop them,
but what it will do is open them up for the consequences of such behavior that
they may have been unaware of and that's what the interaction that the Internet
provides to the average Douche Wad from 20 years ago.
Never experienced.
You're not going to experience if you,
if you're just one of those guys that has some fucking racist thing that you
spout out in your neighborhood and nobody calls you on it,
you know,
maybe cause you're big or maybe because you're important.
Maybe it's because of the neighborhood,
but if you put that shit on your Facebook page and someone takes a photo of it
and then puts it on Reddit,
boom,
Schelok lock,
it's coming at you son fucking thousands of people you never met calling you a
cunt saying they know where you live,
saying they're going to find you and smack the Shit Outta you saying they're
going to shit in your mouth and hold it down.
That's really specific.
People are looking at specific but then of course they get in trouble for
violence and threats because that becomes non anonymous as well.
That's why you should make a real value on Karma points.
Then people wouldn't be dicks and they could actually get something.
You know?
How could you have a real witch?
The exchange that for US dollars,
I don't know,
make it an exchange of coins or angels and demons.
Bitcoin.
Bitcoin is like a,
well now what do you feel I'm going to,
I'm actually an investor in a couple of bitcoin stuff so I'm pretty,
I'm pretty bullish.
I'm not like,
I'm not like this is going to,
I'm not at the 10 level where this is like end of governments and of states like
we are living in it but I am.
I am.
I think I'm most interested in the fact that these like basically transferring
units of value has been really hard and needlessly expensive for too long
because banks make a lot like the taking,
I have to think,
Bank of American charges me $25 to do an overnight wire and it's like,
come on guys,
it's ones and Zeros you don't need,
there's not a bunch of guys in the factory floor being like,
we've got to get this wire to Denmark tomorrow.
Like that's absurd.
And so there's so much,
the financial system has these like a lot of revenue tied into moving ones and
Zeros,
cryptocurrency,
whether it's bitcoin or whether it's Doge coin or whether it's whatever coin,
um,
pause coins he's going to be really is a pocket.
Of course there is.
Yep.
How's the Kardashians coin to?
Wasn't there a Kim Kardashian?
It was a kind of don't want to talk about on this podcast.
All right,
Kim,
prior to the Armenian people and
you can't deny the ass I that is,
that is undeniable.
I'm,
the whole thing is a mess,
but hey,
what are you going to do?
Yeah.
It's part of what makes us fun.
I think part of what makes people find as are falling,
I think that we were all beautiful and perfect and Dalai Lama ask,
come on,
man.
A bunch of people wearing an orange everywhere and no one's getting a dick
sucked.
It'd be ridiculous.
It'd be boring.
It wouldn't sound like fun at all.
Exactly.
There'd be no freakness and people like that wrong or right.
They provide that extra,
that extra stupidity to life that makes the flavor.
It's just like a hint basil in a stew
that just makes the whole thing you can get by without the Bazell,
but it just adds something to it.
Yeah.
The ridiculous fucking dance that we do.
A lot of notes are involved in this ridiculous dance.
All of it together.
It's beautiful though.
Wow.
This symphony of life.
Symphony of life.
Bittersweet is rogue and may be connection to,
but yes,
bullish on cryptocurrencies.
I think it's,
it's gonna be,
it's gonna be real interesting.
Do you owe a Andrea's Antonopoulos?
I feel like I should have.
He should.
He's the Jesus of Bitcoin.
Oh,
he would be on the podcast again on the 22nd and he said he's been preparing for
you.
Brian,
are you hearing,
are you a skeptic Brian?
Through some surprise curve balls at him?
I did.
And he got no,
you were a slight living Brian Skeptical about bitcoin more than I am.
Weird thing is,
is that I don't like how your Ip address is public.
They say it's not like it.
They say it's not.
It is though.
But apparently,
um,
I dunno,
but according to them they say this way is that it's not,
let's find out right now.
Immediately after he gave me some bitcoins,
some other person just gave me some big points.
I'm like,
all right,
so somebody is now stalking me because I've got three points they're giving you.
Oh,
where did this person just immediately just giving you money?
Is this guy just tracking every number and don't be a pushy guy is trying to
give you some money.
And then with the tracking of the Ip address,
I feel like that there's just some weird,
there's something going on that I don't know about.
Yeah,
they don't like it.
Like the Ip address things freaks me out.
All right.
Here it says doing so might leak the fact that you are using bitcoin fog but no
other details.
Um,
okay,
so there's ways around it.
Bitcoin fog is a way around it apparently.
Yeah,
sure.
There's a way around it.
You got use floss.
Yeah.
For the highest level anonymity you need tour.
You wouldn't get tour tours and open source,
open source,
anonymization network for short overview tor,
the tor browser bundle.
So now that the only people that know what you're doing is this company that
just,
I not,
I'm not,
the government says no,
no towards towards legit.
You say so.
But when the fucking tour train,
not the fucking train and into the woods,
where are you going to be?
I'll tell you what we're going to be going to be selling books here is without
their permission.
By Alexis.
Oh,
Hanya.
It's the name of,
Oh,
thank you.
Yeah.
There's no,
there's no title on the cover.
Just the symbols man.
Without their permission.
The,
um,
but real talk,
is this the name of the book without the Oh yeah.
The uh,
the real talk though,
you know,
there is going to be real right now.
Oh yeah.
You keep it in real.
This technology tour is amazeballs.
Uh,
it is the thing when you hear about Chinese dissidents who were looking at
Tienanmen square massacre photos,
right?
Even though there's the great firewall,
it's cause of the tour.
Whoa.
Really?
And this is,
I mean it's been,
it's been like,
it is,
it really is one of those pure forms of,
so it's open source software,
right?
So you can take a look at the source anytime for,
you know,
not only improving it but also just sort of promoting that transparency.
Um,
but it's the thing that lets us actually get through any of the states that want
to try their hardest.
I mean,
China's bet,
a lot of money and a lot of time and a lot of smart people trying to keep the
internet down.
But thanks for the tour and resourceful humans they lose.
That's pretty fucking bad ass.
I love hearing shit like that.
That's such an interesting thing.
When something comes along that just is built by people smarter than your press
and not a business.
It's,
it's an open source project.
It's like a bunch of people got their leg.
I think software is best explained is,
well maybe not best,
but I like explaining it as like Legos and so a bunch of people through the
Internet with like pseudonyms,
so maybe never even met each other in real life.
Brought together their digital lego kits to build something cool that no one had
built before that now lets anyone,
like I said,
open,
uh,
openly surf the Internet in spite of some of the most powerful and repressive
states in the world.
What did you think when that um,
older Japanese gentleman who they credited with creating bitcoin but apparently
maybe didn't they really hounded this fucking guy and waited outside his house
and knocked on his door and this is scary stuff.
It seemed,
it seemed like some rather excessive journalism to say
not just excessive but in correct harassment when they,
but then they
have,
they not,
I know they responded by saying we're sticking to the story.
I don't know if they've since,
well,
of course,
why not stick this story?
It's just some poor little man.
He'd fucking harass.
Even if he did correct,
encrypted or whatever.
A figure it out coded.
If he did create bitcoin or it was one of the people who created Bitcoin,
you have no right to hound him like that and he made it very clear he didn't
want,
yeah,
I mean attention doesn't want anything and you're standing outside of his house
ringing his doorbell,
sticking cameras in his face.
Fuck you man.
You can't do that.
Just the,
there's proper channels.
He's sending a letter or an email.
Would you like to be interviewed?
If not,
leave them the fuck alone.
Yeah.
What the,
what did the guy do that so awful?
The guy came up with some sort of an algorithm to make an alternative currency.
So you think that you're okay to stick a fucking camera in his face and
broadcasted Jim edge without his permission to the whole fucking world.
And now that they're not sure whether or not they're correct or not and it's
awkward.
God Damn,
it's awkward.
It seems like that guy should be getting paid.
What was his name?
Satoshi.
Well,
so Toshi,
he his,
I don't remember what his actual name was.
That was a a pseudonym.
Yeah.
Fucking,
it's scary shit man.
So you can't mask the thing.
That's good.
But the thing that freaked me out though was how in private sort of,
I guess somebody gave me some bitcoins just to show me how to do it and then
later that night I just got who poke but like,
and then so did jam free money.
I know,
but,
but that's like,
that freaks me out.
It's like,
why are people just sending me money now that don't even know who I am?
It's just because of my IP
address.
They have a vested interest in you joining.
Like it's the kind of system that gets more valuable as more people join it and
do business on it.
And I'm just like,
you know,
dollars,
right?
I mean dollars.
You're a store that's valued over most parts of the world because people are
cool doing business in it.
Uh,
so similar idea.
So like,
because it's still at the four,
uh,
everyone who's into this is pretty bullish on it and they want as many other
people that can get on.
I mean,
what's crazy
well you have to do is have people involved that want it to work,
legitimizes it work.
Yeah.
It's just going to take time.
And it's,
it's been,
the challenge for Bitcoin is now is this going to be something people are going
to be buying stuff in online.
So like overstock made headlines,
um,
they partnered with Coinbase,
which is one of those companies I backed by accepting bitcoin and like,
you know,
processing non trivial amounts of money.
People buying furniture in bitcoin online,
uh,
tiger direct doing it on computer.
You guys taking bitcoin donations now we don't take gyrations.
Nope.
There's no only youtube.
My Ip address.
I don't know,
I don't take any direct donations.
Is it safe to put your bitcoin Ip address out to accept bitcoins?
Meaning like I was thinking about doing it but then I was like wait,
so then I have people are like,
no,
you don't want to put your number out publicly,
not your encrypted.
Uh,
this is,
well there is one you definitely do not want to share publicly.
Right.
But you can generate,
so if you use Columbus,
you something else,
you can generate a key that's free to distribute that people will use to give
you a currency sit.
It's very confusing for like that cause I think I almost put out my bad plenty
out to everybody.
There was a combat so then people can just take your,
they take the value that's stored.
Yeah.
Like that Mt.
Gox Shit.
I mean that was one of the most hilarious stories of all time.
The fact that it's all magic,
the gathering and loving life change.
And then from there it becomes one of the biggest bitcoin exchanges on the
internet and it's totally not coded correctly and people are just sticking knife
holes into the bottom of the bag.
It's stealing blood.
The point where hundreds of millions of dollars in Bitcoin is missing.
Yeah.
God cost her who stole all that money?
Do you know?
I,
you know,
what would you tell him?
I'm not allowed to tell you.
You guys don't take guys.
There's plenty.
There's,
there's already plenty of it.
And that's speculation.
Well,
um,
it's weird because it seems like you should be able to track them.
It seems like she'd be able to know where they are.
It seems like that's just another step that's missing from this equation that
would make money all the more,
I mean,
it would really make it all the more tangible if you could track it,
if you know where it was.
I mean,
you have a,
I actually don't know the specifics of the Mt Gox heist.
Um,
but generally speaking,
any one of those transactions is a part of the public register or public record.
Like it's that much.
I mean,
you don't know a lot know or they didn't pay attention while I was going on.
No,
I don't,
I don't actually know the specifics of it.
I think the general consensus
online was it was some kind of an inside job as part of the yeah,
that motherfucker.
I Dunno.
But yeah,
he looks like he might be the inside job type shifty looking,
fuck,
where's my bitcoins?
Yeah.
The uh,
but,
but here's the thing.
After all of those,
you know,
there've been a number of quote unquote crashes and Bitcoin continues to
persevere,
continues to expand.
I mean,
it's it,
and ultimately it may not be bitcoin.
It may be another cryptocurrency.
And I mean,
the Doge coin is an amazing community.
They sponsored a NASCAR at Talladega.
Really?
Um,
they,
they got the Olympic or they got the Jamaican bobsled team.
The Olympics at Sochi.
True Story.
Really?
Yeah.
They did a big fundraiser.
Own crowd tilt raise like 30 grand.
Disney risen to the fucking Olympics.
How about you
cut them checks.
Jesus.
Tiffany [inaudible] come on.
Yeah,
they got it.
Boy,
that was like a big thing for a while.
Like everybody was like,
Megan filed the Jamaican bobsled team.
How hilarious it was.
Then it just lost its novelty.
So they're Doge quarterback,
a resurrection.
So you're more bullish on Doge coin than bitcoin.
You know,
I'm,
no,
I'm excited about cryptocurrency as a whole.
I think bitcoin certainly come the farthest.
Um,
in terms of mainstream,
like there's,
they're random subways in Pennsylvania taking dose coins for your $5 foot long.
Really.
But yeah,
but,
but dozes is this satire that people are actually taking seriously?
Like it's,
it's like,
it's very clearly a joke that everyone's in on,
but even that spirit,
lots of people are like,
yeah,
look,
it's taking the piss out of cryptocurrency and like that's kind of funny.
And its mascot as a she Beano and yeah,
why not?
Uh,
and it's,
it's bizarrely gotten momentum in part on the heels of this tipping system.
So like forever and a day people have pitched Mike Rowe tips,
um,
like decided like flatter was one.
There's another one called tip joy,
where it was like if you're a blogger,
you're a podcast or one of your users can come on and be like,
that was cool.
Here's 5 cents.
And,
and that was really the idea,
saw a lot of pitches for this.
None of them took off.
Uh,
for a variety reasons.
What doge coin has been able to do,
and it exists on Reddit,
it exists on Twitter,
is developers have created these tip bots so that if you say something cool on
Reddit,
you just type in a comment with this particular syntax and it'll tell me,
oh look,
Joe Rogan just tip me 5,000 doge coins.
Now that's actually not a lot of USD,
but it feels like,
hey,
it's 5,000 things.
What is this?
Let me go collect it.
And like,
weirdly enough,
it has gotten a lot of momentum.
And so there's a,
there's,
there are Twitter bots where people are routinely tipping each other in Doge.
But that's a nice sentiment,
like the idea behind it,
but it's all,
and it's all this,
this farce of like to the moon,
which is the ultimate ambition of Doge coin people.
It,
it was originally a bitcoin thing that has really been embraced by the Doge coin
community.
Um,
and I met God.
I met people all over the country where you were at University of central
Florida and some students up on stage with a giant Doge coin.
It wasn't a check,
but like equivalent of what it looked like,
one to present to me because they really wanted me on board with a judge going,
I guess that makes me a Sheba.
She'd know.
Wow.
But a dark,
oh,
there he go.
See?
Oh Wow.
When the Doge coin community finds out about this Joe big deal,
it's going to be a huge deal.
He's half bull dog though.
He's a little guy.
Oh,
bull bull sheep.
What was your sister?
Oh,
I'm going to call him.
Nice dog.
He's a sweetie.
He's very friendly because don't have a photo.
He's got arthritis of my dog.
No,
I don't put pictures of my dogs up online.
You're using Instagram all wrong man.
I got a photo of my cat like every 10.
It's good to move.
Why put your picture up drawing that's not going to get you.
Oh that,
that'll get you a few up votes to something.
I don't know.
Whatever it works,
whatever it gets.
Um,
would you look at the potential that places like reddit and these information
sort of a distribution networks have,
does it kind of freak you out that you're a part of that?
Like you're,
well you're a part of one of the biggest ones.
Like as far as
it wakes me a little bit just cause I still think like,
I,
I still think of it as a project.
My buddy and I just graduated from college.
Like we were eating pizza.
How many employees do you read?
It's up to 40 I'm on the board now,
so I don't see your outside collect and fat checks.
It's not quite
driving around,
grabbing your balls everywhere
is like you were a fly on my wall,
Joe.
I know how you think.
I can tell guys like you,
you got a certain look about you when them ball grabbing stuff.
Myelin.
Do Dee just driving down the street?
It's like you're in my head man.
Um,
does it,
does it feel weird to be a part of it?
Do you feel like an obligation?
Um,
in any way?
I mean,
I think the biggest obligation I felt was during,
uh,
it was two years ago.
The,
so these Sopa Pipa bills,
he's too awful bills.
We're going to break the Internet.
What got me at the time,
I was working on another startup called Hipmunk.
I travel search website and,
and then the Sopa Pipa thing happened and all my friends were like,
please explain to people who don't know what sober people,
um,
the stop online piracy act and the protect Ip act.
And the first is a house bill.
The second was a Senate bill.
Um,
uh,
the entertainment industry basically spent almost a hundred million dollars
lobbying for these two bills to curb piracy.
That was the intent.
And that's what they said,
except the lobbyists who wrote these bills were the like it was,
the bills were embarrassing in terms of how broad and overreach.
He was like a sledge hammer for what they said was a scalpel and it would have
really fucked up the Internet.
It would would've made reddit impossible for me and Steve to start.
It would have made all user generated content a particularly difficult to to
have.
Like it would've really,
really screwed things up.
And I got involved because everyone in DC who knew better than me about politics
said these two bills were inevitable and then was like,
well that's going to really screw things up.
So I borrowed a tie for my dad and I started going and lobbying and like meeting
with senators and representatives and telling them,
look,
I'm an entrepreneur.
I lived this amazing entrepreneurial life thanks to the open internet and if you
pass either these bills,
my story never would have happened.
And,
and so many others just like it never would have.
And you're really screwing up one of the most viable technologies we have.
And I,
long story short,
we won and I say we and I mean hundreds of thousands if not millions of people
who called in like melted the phone lines.
Um,
the webs like 3000 websites went dark on January 18th,
um,
protesting this and it was,
it was amazing.
I had never been a part of something like that that was so successful.
Those bills became toxic for anyone else.
All these senators,
representatives just ran away from them almost overnight and a,
and we won.
Now we haven't totally one cause there's still lots of things that are hurting
the internet.
But um,
that's,
that's where I feel responsibility.
I feel responsible,
be responsible because I know how much this has benefited me and I get to see,
like I said,
I'm on the front lines as an investor these days,
I get to see the kids who were doing even cooler things.
We're going to be even bigger and better things and I don't want to lose that.
I don't want to miss out on so much innovation because we fuck it up because
it's partly in debt.
Like it's partly that I feel indebted,
but it's partly because I just want better stuff.
I want better music and I want better,
I want better politics,
I want better technology.
And the Internet is a gateway for that.
Do you think the Internet is safe?
Do you think it's passed through that?
No,
definitely not.
What could be done?
I mean,
how,
how do you stop this tide?
All right.
So first and foremost,
um,
so net neutrality took a huge blow.
And,
and let me say this like I'm,
I'm fond of saying the world isn't flat.
Uh,
sorry,
Tom Freeman.
But the worldwide web is,
and what that means is I can start a website with my buddy.
We have no connections and we just have like an Internet connection and some
laptops and we can build something that nine years later we'll have more traffic
than the c New York Times or CNN.
And that works because all,
all bits are created equal.
You can get to my brand new website,
reddit.com,
you know,
nine years ago,
just as easily as New York times.com and you get to decide,
do I want to go to read it or do you want to go to New York Times?
It's just as easy to get to.
We're now in a position where cable companies,
because they basically,
I have,
um,
oligopolies,
right?
There's only a handful of them,
um,
want to break this.
They don't want the Internet to be flat.
They want it to look like your cable.
They want you to have a basic package,
right where you get,
you get being searched for free because they've made a deal with Microsoft.
If you want Google,
it's an extra $10 a month,
but it's a really good search engine,
so you'll,
you'll pay for it,
right?
But then if you want,
if you want,
you know,
Joe sixpacks new search engine,
well that's,
that's gonna be an extra 50,
but you probably don't want that anyway.
And so now the entrepreneur,
the upstart,
the nobody's in the apartment have a much smaller percentage of the market
because they're not part of the default Internet package anymore.
Right.
So trying to start your own cable company.
Yeah.
Good luck.
Yeah,
good luck.
And it rather than just getting a youtube channel and start the broadcast.
And so what used to be a flat internet will become hierarchical and will be
like,
you'll have that cable bill or you'll have that internet,
but looking just like your cable bill and,
and it's,
it breaks the foundation of what makes the Internet work.
All bits being equal.
And we're at a point now where judges in the federal courts recently ruled it
pretty much were cable companies can have their way now.
And,
and at this point in my,
but my buddy,
I'm at the verge now,
he's at vox,
but wrote an article called the Internet is fucked.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Neil,
I really nailed it with this and he basically had a nice little call to arms
that was like,
listen,
at this point,
call the FCC.
I know it seems ridiculous.
Um,
call the FCC and let them know they need to give this thing teeth because the
internet is a utility.
Like it is like electricity.
Uh,
it is the kind of thing where we all know we need it.
We couldn't imagine a world without it and every one of us should have the same
open flat internet no matter what.
And,
and we're at an interesting time because there was a time in America when you
know kids and in New York we're playing by radios with electricity and kids in
the south.
We're still using candles like this.
We've seen this disparity before,
but um,
we,
we can change it.
We just have to make sure the Internet becomes a utility that we know.
The last thing we want is the internet only to be available in its fullest form
to people that pay for the premium subscription rate.
Shad since Sam oven.
Oh yeah.
It is insanity.
And it's,
it's anti innovation.
I mean,
and anybody that would want that,
it's just trying to control innovation.
That's absolutely,
you just try and control information.
Do you think,
is there a way to stop that?
At this point in time.
I mean,
I mean realistically,
seriously call the FCC,
you can read the article if you're not totally convinced,
he goes in,
I mean it's like 30 pages but worth reading.
Um,
but really that's,
that's a big part of it.
Another part of it is,
is frankly having representatives in office who understand and will fight for
our Internet rights and there aren't a lot of them there.
Maybe like six or eight.
Now there's not a lot.
And um,
I mean we talked earlier about our uplifting discussion about the future of
politics and politicians,
but like that's,
that's where we're at right now.
Unfortunately.
That's what it comes down to.
And then you have to call the FCC.
That's the only way to sort of game and,
and call,
I mean having,
here's,
here's the other thing that I hope can come out of this,
right?
The first political thing I ever got involved with,
with Sopa Pipa.
And that was a dangerous thing for a lot of us to get involved with because it
worked out so well.
Like we actually did the thing democracy was supposed to do,
which is let a bunch of informed citizens take action,
phone calls,
petitions,
letters,
all that stuff,
and change people's minds in the face of millions of dollars in lobbying.
And we did it.
And it was a,
it was a great high,
especially for like a first foray into politics.
But the fact is there are many more of those fights that we need to keep
fighting.
And like,
I want,
I hope a more connected,
I hope a more connected citizen feels entitled to this kind of stuff.
I hope we feel entitled to more transparency from our government.
I hope we feel entitled to like,
like to pick on Kim.
Like we can look on Kim's in Instagram right now and see what she's having for
breakfast or what you had for,
and that's ridiculous.
That's absurd.
But it's accessible to millions of people right now.
24,
seven.
I want that same level of accountability for the people who represent me in
government for my government.
Uh,
and there's no reason why we can't get it.
We just need to be asking for it.
Yeah.
But not necessarily the same their lines,
but yeah.
See important bills that they're working on and what's going on at any given
moment.
Probably having,
they should have 24 hour.
Camera's on them.
Fuck it.
I'm gonna read your email image.
I can't edit.
You even get to read them.
They get to read ours,
so they're already ruined them.
It's only fox.
Um,
tell me about Aaron Schwartz.
Well,
wow.
Um,
so he was in the same round of y Combinator that Steve and I were,
he was working on a startup called Infogami.
Um,
we didn't talk a lot then,
um,
but maybe six months after,
he,
his company pretty much folded his cofounder,
went back to Denmark and Paul Graham who organized the y Combinator.
It was like,
Hey,
Steve,
Alexis,
you guys need more developers.
Why don't you work with Erin?
And we acquired his company.
He moved in with us.
We worked together for a little bit.
Um,
we,
gosh,
not long thereafter got acquired.
Um,
once we got acquired,
it was clear.
Aaron was not,
not really that into it.
And he left and we stayed in touch for a little bit thereafter,
but not long.
Uh,
and then he got really into politics,
really started getting involved in a lot of that great work for the open
Internet.
Um,
we shared a lot of common friends and you know,
he,
he did some very,
he did some very unfairly punished things.
Like he did the entire thing.
He a broken to a storeroom and MIT,
um,
downloaded using MIT's credentials,
a bunch of these documents,
uh,
research papers.
But Jason,
we're like,
these are academic articles,
downloaded a bunch of them and um,
and put them online.
All right.
Well he didn't actually put them online.
Um,
but he did download them and there was presumed intent,
but none of that.
That was all presumed.
And,
uh,
the state or the prosecutor there in Boston came down so incredibly and unjustly
hard on him.
Uh,
the charges they were levying,
I mean,
I,
I don't know much more than what probably most people have read a few of the
articles.
No.
Um,
but he was looking at some very,
very,
very long,
serious jail time for this.
Um,
it was one of those very clear,
the punishment did not fit the crime situations.
They wanted to make an example of him and,
um,
he very tragically took his own life.
Um,
rather than risk going to jail.
Was He prosecuted?
What does that like he,
they'd go through and charge him and,
yeah.
I mean,
did he believe you get found guilty?
Oh,
no,
this is,
I don't know enough.
Okay.
I have stuff of it.
Um,
he was,
he was being investigated.
His friends,
his family were being subpoenaed and question what these papers that he put up,
were they available?
Could you get those?
Yes.
If
they weren't secret,
know what it is.
This is,
this is one of those really unjust things.
Um,
there's a lot of research that's done,
like federal research for instance,
that's funded with our taxpayer dollars that ended up getting locked up in these
like,
um,
academic journals that you have to pay a subscription for.
So in this case,
MIT had paid the subscription for and it's a nontrivial amount.
And,
and he was able to,
anyone on the MIT network,
anyone at probably any major university network or anyone who wanted to pay
could view these research documents.
He argued that,
you know what this is,
this is content we paid for it.
This research was funded by our tax dollars.
Why should I have to pay a subscription to some random company who has the
monopoly on access to this content?
And that is what that is what they charge them with.
Um,
and I mean,
sorry.
Well that,
that is that those are the grounds on which he was charged.
So it was a felony because he was breaking and entering into the system.
Uh,
I,
I mean I think certain,
but it,
sure.
That's what the argument is.
And then there was some really egregious,
ah,
like there are,
there have been a handful of developers or hackers that have been sort of made
examples of by the government where you have these instances of doing things
that were not like,
right.
Like I said,
the severity of the punishment did not even come close to the actual crime,
especially in this instance where like I said,
this was not actually distributed.
He was just downloading them,
which again,
he could do within the network,
but it was technically breaking the,
I don't know,
the level of licensed,
I guess Jason or I guess.
Okay.
And one of these,
not even like a random outside guy,
like he had access to those files.
I mean any university student did and,
and I think the most egregious we'll one of,
okay,
there are a lot of gauges things,
but the company Jay Store had actually settled up with him.
They had actually said,
you know what,
we understand like,
okay,
it's cool.
We don't want you to press charges.
So like they actually told the government don't press charges and,
and they continued.
And um,
so is that like a prosecutor that just wants to get a win?
Is that what that is?
That is,
that is what it looked like.
Yeah.
Uh,
just chilling.
And that takes us back to what we were talking about earlier about private
prisons and about people making sure that there's jobs for wardens and prison
guards and they're making sure that certain drug laws stay illegal or stay on
the books.
God,
yeah,
it's the same thing.
People profiting off of other folks.
And the idea of someone just wanting to win when they're a prosecutor,
just getting a case and wanting to close it and make an exam.
Then there's pressure on you to close that case.
And if you don't,
you set a precedent.
If the guy gets off then the precedent has been set.
So it becomes a competitive environment.
Yeah.
Mother fucker and some young guys,
life is on the line.
It's a,
and I,
and I understand,
I understand the role.
I mean like I understand the role of laws and understand the role of a justice
system and,
and when you see things like that seemed to fall,
that seem to go so far astray from the intense,
from the point of having a,
it just the system is really important.
But to have it be so just fucked up like gun is,
um,
is,
is very,
very sad.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's another symptom of this mad mad civilization that we're a part of.
Like the good things and the bad things.
They all to come together and law as it is and things.
He's really rigid ideas of what's legal and illegal with the punishment can and
can't be.
It's those things are so God damn archaic,
mandatory minimums.
Mandatory minimums are fucking archaic.
I mean,
it's one thing if it's violent crime,
I understand that entirely.
I understand when you're making a victim out of someone or you're stealing
things from them with violence,
I get that.
But something like this where the guys just,
it's information.
What's he doing?
This information?
It's going to take down the government.
No,
no,
no.
He's going to let people learn.
Okay.
Hold the fuck up because someone in the room stand up.
Yeah.
Like,
hey guys,
you want to put this guy in a cage and you got a super genius who has some
incredibly strong morals and ethics when it comes to information.
And to him he feels,
I know you got a guy who's at the cutting edge of technology,
one of the guys who helped invent RSS feeds.
He's at the cutting edge of the distribution of information and he finds this to
be a toxic flaw in the system.
He wants it,
whether he's right or wrong,
you don't have to put them in a fucking cage.
Like this is the idea that this is the right thing to do.
It's just,
it's shocking.
It's like,
it's like inquisition style.
Shocking.
It's like the same thing is any of the other ridiculous,
archaic things that we don't do anymore.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
And hopefully,
hopefully we can learn from this.
I know,
you know,
I hope so.
Erin's law.
Uh,
was it bill?
I don't know.
I don't know where it got in the house.
Um,
but I hope,
I mean this is look right like the,
the,
the thing that gives me hope is that this system is,
is uh,
like it's like code and that you can,
you can update it.
You can do a source for video.
Like you can,
you can update this,
right?
We can make amendments,
we can change things.
We find that they are wrong and Erin's law is a way to hopefully do that.
But you've got to get a bunch of people who don't understand the Internet to
agree on stuff.
It's incredibly ironic.
His solution is reddit have court cases decided through reddit.
Whoa.
It's the perfect,
no does not.
Well because the alternative is,
whoa.
The fact that we're using this archaic system of a judge fucking has a mallet
and slams it on a piece of wood.
What are you doing asshole?
You've got a mallet.
Get the fuck Outta here with you.
Why don't you have a a fucking bow and Arrow too,
and shooting a flaming Arrow through the sky to let us know that the games would
be gone and the guy next to you as a conch shell off and put your powdered wigs
on.
You fucking assholes.
Get the fuck out of here with a mallet.
You can't keep using a mallet.
Stupid Bank Bank Bank.
Get the fuck Outta here with that stupid archaic nonsense.
Red.
It's the answer.
No judges get 'em out of reddit.
Subreddits,
subreddits,
agriculture.
Should we be able to grow hemp?
Shh.
Yes.
Boom.
We're done.
We're done here.
That went up on to the next one.
Okay.
Should this guy go to jail because he distributes information that it was freely
available to college students?
No.
Okay,
we're good.
Let them out.
What's next?
You would run into the problem if there would be somebody that had like a
stutter or something like that,
or if that joke turned on them,
then everyone would vote just because of the wrong reason.
You know how the Internet is what meaning like what if there was somebody that
came when I had a court case and they were being voted on Reddit and the guy had
you know,
maybe had a stutter or talked like he was gay or something like that.
How that could turn and unfairly vote for the wrong reason on the Internet.
I did see that's where the vote up and vote downs come into play.
I am.
I'm going to be the first to say,
I am not proposing we throw out our justice system in favor.
I am.
I'll be the first Sam.
All right.
I'll throw out the justice system and favorite reddit.
I think it's a better idea.
I think,
look,
there's certainly should it be experts in all areas,
whether it's experts on the environment and
uninfluenced experts,
experts that have no tie to the political machine experts who have no
aspirations.
Not only that,
preclude them from having any sort of off and any sort of position of power or
any sort of gigantic job inside a corporation,
like what we're seeing.
Did you see the movie inside job?
Do you ever see that?
Wait,
I feel like I did.
It was on the financial crisis.
Fascinating documentary.
No,
no really good stuff.
Let me pull it up.
Yeah,
you,
you want to watch it.
But one of the interesting things about it was how they highlighted how these
people that made economic policy,
these professors,
they recommended these positions that,
you know,
we apply to our economy.
Then they would go on and get these huge jobs afterwards and make fucking
millions of dollars and interesting coincidence.
Oh,
it's so gross.
It's one of the grossest things ever.
It's a really good documentaries from 2010.
Uh,
and uh,
it's by a guy named Charles Ferguson.
And what's interesting is this,
Charles Ferguson guy is,
I believe he's the guy that's doing all of all of the,
uh,
the questions.
Um,
I shouldn't say that cause I'm not really sure,
but whoever the guy is that the narrator,
you don't see him always questioning people,
boys questioning people.
He's so knowledgeable about how the system actually works,
that he catches these,
these like mathematicians and these economic textbook.
It's being really arrogant.
And then he faces the them with the truth and you see them scramble and start to
sweat.
And God,
I should've never agreed to this interview.
Like you see them realize you're Google what you're going to do with this and
you see them like fall apart and panic and they fall into this like really sort
of a aggressive state.
It's,
it's quite fascinating job.
It's really good.
And it just shows you like that.
It's,
it's a mess.
Read it up,
fix it.
Vote up,
vote down problems.
And I think we aren't dude.
We're selling
private about it.
I feel good about this conversation.
I think we should end here before it gets bad as long as uh,
as long as we just remember.
Uh,
there's going to be a mascot,
right?
We're going to keep the,
the red at alien gone.
I liked it.
That's a great mascot.
It's cute.
Yes.
Sweet.
Doesn't it mean,
have you ever thought about,
this is probably what happened to dig in a couple other similar sites,
just redesigning the whole thing.
It's all up.
You don't want to fuck everything.
But what if it was just an option?
Almost like,
like you can go into your settings and go,
oh,
new,
I'll take your modern.
No.
Have you ever thought about it?
We've definitely thought about modernizing it.
Um,
part of it's just the nurture.
Like you're,
you're dealing with growth all the time.
You're dealing with all this other stuff.
It's like,
Oh,
do we want to rethink how the front page looks like?
There have been small improvements.
We just added trending subreddits,
which are pretty damn cool.
Um,
to try to help people realize that,
that there are these thousands of different communities they should dive into.
Um,
I,
but I wouldn't expect any big changes.
I mean,
for the reasons we were just joking about it.
Like if it's not broke,
you know,
I mean,
it's a content distribution network.
Me,
your,
your face,
you're essentially,
you're allowing people to like really cleanly,
easily find something they're interested in text form and then go there the best
way.
Make it light,
keep it light and help me look.
It's not like there was some minimal vision.
Like when we graduated from college,
Steven,
I just sucked at html and CSS,
like this was the first real web app we'd ever made.
We made websites but never like a fully featured web app.
And uh,
we just weren't very good.
So like,
that's cool.
That was my fault that that shitty font we use.
Vedana that's,
it was like,
oh,
this would be a great spot by the domain.
Where you the first yes sir.
What was it originally purchased for?
Oh,
it was,
it was unreal.
It was unused nine,
nine 93 minutes.
Oh,
I was,
I was in the library,
Eva Alderman Library,
while who,
uh,
and uh,
and I was trying to come up with something that involves the word read and I was
like,
Reddit,
like I read it on Reddit and then I tried different ways of spelling it and red
d it works cause no one had it.
And I also registered Red Itt.
But then I asked my friend Melissa,
I was like,
which one of these makes more sense for a bastardization of read it?
And she was like,
I'll go with the two ds idiot.
And I was like,
that's great man.
Well listen eats,
it's what you guys did was nothing short of a cultural revolution I think in my
opinion.
I think it's,
it's one of the key components today online as far as like the uh,
I can asset to distribute information to spread cool shit and to let people,
you know,
have like intelligent discussions about it and it really rational way of
filtering out the fuck heads.
You know?
It's pretty genius stuff man.
Well,
uh,
thank you.
You're here.
I am.
I am happy we could do it because I'll tell you man,
it,
it was just,
we were just trying to live like college students for as long as we could.
Your book is without their permission.
Is it available in audio?
Did you do an audio version of it and did the jungle,
did you get to talk?
It was great.
Yeah,
I they did.
Oh,
they encourage you to
fall.
Oh,
that's so good.
It was for the Bain impression.
What's the thing you like to do on pain?
Impression?
What's your pain impression?
I mean,
it doesn't Mater Watch you.
And think of my bedroom pressure.
No,
I know.
Impression humor is like the lowest form of humor.
The lowest form.
I don't believe in that,
man.
I think you got an impression.
It's hilarious.
Hilarious.
People are so pretentious when it comes to that.
We had a laugh track.
Nope.
We already had a lab track.
He was laughing.
That's the lap traffic.
Okay,
so without their permission and a audible.com you have the audio version,
the real version.
We Amazon sell it everywhere you book dead trees,
everything.
And how would your grandfather say it on Alexis Ohanian and props for keeping
the name Alexis because she,
yeah.
Fuck the haters.
Oh yeah.
Let them rot.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's it.
That's a wrap.
Anything else?
Tell people no.
Thank you for having me,
man.
Thanks for being on.
It's been an honor.
reddit.com r e d d,
I t,
go get on of bitches and uh,
on it,
uh,
dot com our sponsor,
thanks to on it,
use the codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
Thanks also to legal zoom.com.
Use the code word Rogan at checkout and save yourself some money.
Brian Red Van.
Well yet.
Uh,
next week we'll be going on the road with death squad with Tony Hinchcliffe and
Tiffany Haddish.
We're going to be in Portland,
Oregon in April 18th at the fun house,
April 19th,
Seattle at the high line in April 20th,
four 20 show at the edge water casino.
And also if you go back,
you can listen to pointless number four.
We actually had you on,
uh,
on a desk squad show,
back in the day.
Boom.
Schelok lock.
All right.
Um,
will be this Friday night.
We'll be at the ice house tonight,
tonight,
tonight.
Tickets,
tickets left.
Who else is there with us?
Uh,
we got Tony Hinchcliffe,
[inaudible],
Christina,
Shit's Jesus Christ.
Justin Martin,
Nick Usaa.
I show Dave Taylor what our show and is only 80 people in the room.
It's a fucking amazing little venue at the Ice House,
the oldest comedy club in the country.
Ladies and gentlemen.
It's been a comedy club since the 1960s,
I believe.
1961 or something like that.
Anyway,
we'll be there.
Don't get too weird with us though.
Uh,
thanks.
to everybody else and a lot of fucking the good shit coming up next week.
Uh,
I got a Amy Schumer's coming in again.
Um,
I got a lot of stuff out,
but I got the new Twitter profile and I'm so jealous.
Why was it hard to get
slowly released to a few people?
Oh,
well did I get lucky?
You got the navy.
Somebody loves me.
Wait a minute,
somebody loves me.
Brian might not be lucky.
Loaves me.
Why you got to hate?
All right.
Um,
we,
we love you guys.
Even if you'd get a whack ass Twitter profile,
nothing but love for you.
Big kisses and hugs all around and [inaudible].
All right,
we'll see you guys next week.
Take care.
Big Kiss.
Bye.
Right.